Mon-Mon-Mon-Mon-Monka W!
Juventus!
Mon-Mon-Mon-Monka W!
get rekt
chat da bin ich muss noch kurz die tür zu machen war mal kurz
jetzt aber 9 excellent ja rare stream oder dienstag 17 uhr kommt eigentlich nie vor
mir war es so danach dass nur für euch high IQ chat habe ich mir gedacht bevor ich jetzt
irgendwas anderes machen machen wir noch ein bisschen gebastelt mit dem nass weil
Irgendwann muss es ja auch mal fertig werden.
Exzellent.
Leute, nächste Woche.
Wisst ihr, was nächste Woche gemacht wird?
Wobei, das erzähle ich gleich.
Der Stream ist ja immer richtig angelaufen.
Ich kann es euch sagen, nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche wird geschuckt.
Richtig heftig geschuckt wird da.
Da werden Festplatten geschuckt.
Ich finde dieses Wort so geil irgendwie.
Geschuckt wird er.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht,
was das eigentlich heißen soll.
Too shook.
Meaning.
Heißt,
auskernen.
Enthülsen.
Okay.
Nächste Woche wird enthülst, Leute.
Enthülst wird.
Rare Stream.
Sag ich ja.
Enthülst wird nächste Woche.
in tülsen schock schock schock schock genau das war mir nächste woche welches linux ist
das beste für game je nachdem wie eine fragst bitte dir was andere sagen es gibt so 33 hype
dinger zurzeit wenn es um linux gaming geht das ist cash us nubara und besit oder besit
wie man das genau ausspricht ich persönlich bin cash ios enjoyer wenn übrigens wo wir gerade bei
cash ios enjoyer sind müsste ich vielleicht mal starten das verdammte spiel leute so jetzt müsste
ich auch mal irgendwie automatisieren sonst sieht das immer so so billig aus wenn man das von hand
aufklicken muss.
Urlaub, ne.
Ich bin in Schucking-Laune.
Es wird geschuckt mit nächster Woche.
Oh Gott, wer weiß, wie oft
heute ich dieses dumme Wort noch sage.
Ich sehe es schon kommen.
Für jedes
zweite Satz wird Schuck drin vorkommen.
Ja, ich habe mir nämlich
eine externe Festplatte bestellt.
Arbeitszeitbetrug.
Ich bin seit
15 Uhr
15.
Fertig. Ich bin 15.30 Uhr.
Bin ich in Frankfurt weg
von der Arbeit.
Dann habe ich noch gemietet.
Unterwegs. Wo es vollkommen egal ist, ob ich im Büro sitze
oder nur Remote dabei bin.
Und dann war ich so 15.15 Uhr
fertig. Da habe ich mich ausgelockt.
Und dann bin ich heimgelaufen.
Ich habe ein bisschen was vom schönen Wetter
mitgekriegt.
Dass man nächste Woche ordentlich shoppen kann.
So, da sind wir
Meine lieben Schuckers
Äh, Chat
Ich hab jetzt so viel geschuckt, dass
Meine Logitech-Software nicht gestartet ist
Richtig high IQ-Stream
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie sehr mich das ankotzt
Dass mittlerweile alle Anwendungen
Eigentlich nur noch im Browser sind
Und abfuck langsam
warum braucht ein maustreiber 20 sekunden zum starten meine hardware ist
ja schon erkannt so ist es ja nicht
und das ist ich wette mit euch guckt euch mal hier oben diese ecken an das ist
garantiert ein browser das ist gar nicht irgendein chrome unter der haube und das
ist dieses komische ecken css back
So, da sind wir.
Äh, Firefox-Stand.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Chaterino.
Terminal.
Hier, da sind wir.
Das habe ich auch gelesen.
Hier, diese Geschichte.
Microsoft hat den Co-Pilot-Discord-Server geschlossen, weil die Leute zu sehr Microslop gepostet haben in allen möglichen erdenklichen Varianten.
Und dann haben die gesagt, ne, das geht nicht.
Das ist zu belastend für ihren CEO.
Oder keine Ahnung, ob sie das gesagt haben.
Und dann haben sie den Discord-Server zugemacht.
50 streak das ist aber exzellent
ich weiß es ist eine ziemlich schlechte zeit zu streben ja es ist dienstag mitten in der woche
die meisten leute sind es nicht mal mehr auf der arbeit dass die irgendwie im homeoffice
gucken können oder so diese jetzt auf dem heimweg aber so ist es gibt nur die
auswahl jetzt oder kein stream und ich denke da bevorzugen wir alle inklusive
mir einen stream wirst es keinen stream
easy arbeitslos das problem bei arbeitslos ist dass zu wenig geld gibt
es sei denn es sei denn was habe ich letztens gelesen wenn du acht kinder
hast und wie heißt das was man als asylbewerber für geld bekommt ja dann
kriegst du sieben karl monat ist aber aber disclaimers stand eine bildzeitung
wer weiß ja und was besonders witzig fand der typ ist mit vornamen huso
die bildzeitung hat sich doch wieder irgendwas ausgedacht never kann das kann
das ein realistischer echter name sein wie heißt der mit vornamen es wird
huso name von der redaktion geändert oder sowas acht kinder wenn sieben k
Hey, wenn du 7k im Monat überwiesen kriegst, machen wir auch 8 Kinder.
Easy.
Oh, seit unserem letzten Einkaufsstream hat sich da ein bisschen was geändert.
Meine Schuhe sind teurer geworden.
Aber die habe ich mittlerweile schon bestellt.
Kistenberg ist 1 Cent günstiger geworden.
Und das NVMe SATA.
Warum steht da SATA?
Das hat doch legit absolut null mit SATA zu tun, dieses Ding.
Da kommt eine NVMe SSD rein und die geht auf USB-C.
Da ist nichts SATA drin.
Absolut gar nichts.
Ist da SATA?
Oder machen SSDs intern irgendwie immer noch SATA-Protokoll?
Egal, wie schnell es ist.
Ach, whatever.
Wurscht.
Haben wir eigentlich ASCII-Quarium installiert?
Wichtig.
Allerwichtigste ist installiert.
Da kann nichts mehr schief gehen.
Easy.
Kurz gucken, ob wir mal updaten müssen hier.
Check for updates.
Oh.
Muss man hier updaten.
Wie war das bei Cache?
Man kann
Einfach Update eingeben, oder?
Die kann mit einer M2
Ach, das meinst du
Stimmt, das ist ja kein
Vorbestücktes SATA
SSD, NVMe, SSD Enclosure
Das ist ja eins, wo du selbst eine reinmachen kannst
Okay, dann macht es Sinn
Du kannst eine SATA
NVMe, ne, wie heißt das dann richtig?
eine M2, nicht NVMe,
eine M2 SATA SSD
reinstecken.
Ich weiß, die Zeit
ist unglücklich zum Streamen, aber so ist
es halt.
Hast du auch eine von den Boxen bestellt,
die ich dir gezeigt habe? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was du gezeigt hast.
Zum Schucken.
Ne, was ich bestellt habe, ist folgendes.
Guck mal, ich habe ein
Seagate
Desktop
Expansion bestellt.
Und zwar
26 Terabyte.
Die kosten nur,
nur, ja nur,
499 Euro.
Also die, ne, ne, ne,
26T Festplatte kostet
irgendwie sonst, genau,
700 oder so.
Und das Ding habe ich bestellt
Und das wird dann nächste Woche geschuckt
Was angeblich gehen soll
Ich habe mir das vorher auf YouTube angeguckt
Dort gab es ein Video
Seagate Desktop Expansion
Äh Schuck
Eins erstmal zum testen
Guck mal
Und hier sieht man
Wie das einer schuckt das Ding
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, wenn er das mit so einer billigen Kreditkarte schucken kann
Dann kann ich das mit meinem ordentlichen Schucking-Gear auch schucken
Ja, so einen Spachtel habe ich auch da
Dann habe ich noch so Plastikdinger, um Gehäuse aufzumachen
Vielleicht kriege ich ja sogar so auf, dass es nicht komplett kaputt ist
Und man kann das externe Gehäuse für eine Platte noch verwenden
Aber nicht unbedingt für die 26T-Platte
Guck hier, das machen wir dann nächste Woche
Ich glaube am 11. März kommt die
Also es dauert noch, dauert noch
Also nächste Woche können wir das was machen
Am 11. März wird es laut Amazon geliefert
Das ist die
Ready to Shook
Guck und hier
Hier holt er sie raus
Okay, das Gehäuse ist ein bisschen kaputt danach
Aber wen juckt's
Und da ist angeblich
Eine 26T Seagate Platte drinne.
Nicht SMR.
SMR heißt, oder?
Diese überlappenden Sektor-Dinger auf der Festplatte.
Überlappenden Magnet-Dinger.
SMR.
Ja, ja, hier.
Shinglet Magnetic Recording.
schingelt, schinglet,
was auch immer.
Die taugen nix.
Aber das ist angeblich keine SMR-Platte.
Sagt zumindest Reddit,
das müssen wir dann überprüfen, ob das wirklich so ist.
Man kann das testen mit ein paar Benchmarks
und das dann so ganz grob
mal einschätzen, ist das eine, ist das eine nicht.
Tape Drive
brauch ich nicht, wozu?
Und selbst, und selbst wenn, deswegen hab ich auch erstmal nur eine
bestellt, selbst wenn
das Ding ne SMR-Platte
ist, kann ich die als Backup-Festplatte
benutzen, wo halt einmal nachts drauf AirSynced wird.
Das ist mit einer SMR-Platte auch
vollkommen okay. Ja, ins
RAID, wo öfters was drauf passiert,
will ich das nicht unbedingt packen.
Gerade mit ZFS nicht.
Aber für
nächtliches AirSync auf eine
Platte, die ansonsten halt einfach nur
rumgammelt und aus ist oder
spin down ist,
ist das ja eigentlich top. Selbst wenn es SMR ist.
Wenn es nicht SMR ist, umso besser.
Dann werde ich einfach mal Nass damit
ausstatten weil ich spare 700 nicht 700 euro ich spare 200 euro pro platte übrigens habt ihr das
gelesen es ist wobei es hat letztens auch einer im stream geschrieben da ist jemand
ja da ist einer aus england in die usa geflogen um festplatten zu kaufen das hotel und seinen
flug hat ein bisschen günstiger gekriegt weil er bei der airline wohl irgendwie punkte gesammelt
hat und da war es für den billiger in die usa zu fliegen und sich zwölf platten oder so zu kaufen
als die bei sich in england zu kaufen soweit sind wir schon was ich aber ehrlich gesagt nicht checke
ist vielleicht kann mir das einer von euch erklären der mehr IQ drin hat warum sind die
festplatten so viel billiger in den usa weil ich dachte die lieferengpässe treffen schlicht und
ergreifend alle auf der welt warum sind platten in den usa so viel billiger
das können keine gema gebühren sein das ist ein riesenunterschied
und die waren vorher auch schon drauf
das können keine gema gebühren sein oder sind gema gebühren prozentual sind
Sind die prozentual oder sind die pro Festplatte?
Das kann nicht so viel sein.
Das kann auch keine 300, 400 Euro ausmachen.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Nee, in den USA.
Der hat die in den USA gekauft, die Platten.
Der ist von England in die USA geflogen,
hat dort, glaube ich, 12 Festplatten vorbestellt.
Steht hier irgendwo.
Guck mal, 280 Euro kosten die in den USA.
In England hätten die 56 Euro gekostet.
Bei uns kostet die mittlerweile 700 Euro oder sowas.
Können wir mal gucken.
Geiz.
Hals.
Und der hat die vorbestellt.
Leute, das finde ich auch witzig.
Noch im Hotelzimmer in New York wurden alle 10 Laufwerke ausgepackt und mit Diagnose-Software auf ihre Funktionsfähigkeit geprüft.
Für den Rückflug nutzte der Anwender die Schaumstoffeinlagen der Originalverpackung, um die empfindlichen Datenträger sicher im Handgepäck zu verstauen.
Die haben bestimmt blöd geguckt, als sie sein Gepäck kontrolliert haben.
Was haben sie denn da für komische Geräte drin?
Also, der hat ordentlich Kohle gespart, obwohl er in die USA geflogen ist.
Was ich auch schon geguckt habe, Festplatten in Dänemark sind tatsächlich billiger als hier.
Warum? Ich weiß es nicht.
Guck mal, wenn man hier sucht nach Einwolf 28,
dann sind das 6.287 dänische Kronen.
Wenn man das zu Euro rechnet, dann sind es so 583.
Warum ist bei uns der ganze Scheiß immer so unglaublich teuer?
Die können wir nicht alle mal.
Ich bestelle demnächst alles nur noch bei den China-Chinesen, ey.
Was kosten die Festplatte bei AliExpress?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Das waren schwedische Kronen?
Moment.
Warum ist auf einer dänischen Seite
eine schwedische Kronen?
Das macht doch keinen Sinn.
Ach hier, schwedische Kronen.
Achso.
Dänische Kronen.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Okay, das ist ja noch teurer als bei uns.
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt.
Das kostet ja in Dänemark
nochmal mehr.
841 Euro.
Was?
Ali Express,
Alter.
WTF.
Unusual traffic from your network.
Ja, ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ich dedos die China-Chinesen.
Okay, jetzt funktioniert es.
Whatever.
Moment, Alibaba?
Ich will jetzt AliExpress.
Okay.
ähm, so
ah, AliExpress, die Webseite
ist so schlimm teilweise
ich muss mal kurz
den Dark Mode aus
guck mal, was
das standardmäßig ausgefüllt ist
seht ihr das?
Taschen-Mutschis
Männer
AliExpress beste.
Ich hatte auf dieser Kiste nicht einmal...
Ich habe nicht einmal auf dieser Kiste AliExpress-Mission offen gehabt.
Oh shit, Alter.
Was ist das hier unten?
Das ist Toss.
Das ist ja Toss.
Was geht hier unten ab, Alter?
Was ist hier?
Du gehst auf AliExpress und hast irgendwelche...
Alter.
AliExpress, please.
Please.
Na, zum Glück sieht man keine Nippel, dann ist das nicht Toss.
Ähm, ich wollte eigentlich nur nach Festplatte HDD 28 TB suchen.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Maßgeschneidert, hochwertige 4 TB.
Okay, was kostet 26 TB?
Der Kombi-Knaller, ja.
Gibt's bei AliExpress nicht.
Die haben nur so billige Sachen mit 4 Terabyte oder sowas.
Was? 4 Terabyte? 8 Terabyte? 18 Terabyte? What?
20 Terabyte? 22 Terabyte?
Bei den China-Chinesen teuer, ne?
Kann man die auch schucken?
Wofür ich Speicherplatz brauche? Weil ich mein altes NAS ablöse.
Da habe ich aktuell, und mein Plan war eigentlich die alten Festplatten weiter zu verwenden, da habe ich aktuell 3 10TB drin.
Und ich dachte mir so, ey, warum nicht ein bisschen mehr.
Das Ding ist nur
Wenn ich einmal anfange mit 26T
Dann brauche ich ja von den anderen auch 26T
Also wird es dann im Endeffekt
Darauf rauslaufen, dass ich noch ein paar mal schucken muss
Hm
Ich glaube von meinem Nas sind ungefähr
Von den 10TB sind keine Ahnung
Wenn es hochkommt, 30% oder so belegt.
Das sind iPhone-Backups, Rechner-Backups, VM-Backups und ein paar Docker-Container.
Und Linux-ISOs natürlich.
China DDR5 RAM.
DDR5 32GB.
China-Chinesen-Ramm. Jawoll!
Kingston.
Ne, das ist mir zu legit.
Hier, Pooskill.
Klingt doch schon mal gut, ja.
8 Gig, 16 Gig, 32 Gig.
Aber Leute, warum ist sogar China-Chinesen-Ramm teuer?
Wenn sogar China-Chinesen-Ramm teuer ist.
Okay, okay.
Buu-Skill.
32 Gig.
307 Euro.
Ich glaube, das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Wartet mal kurz.
Ja.
Nee, das ist teuer.
Das ist teuer.
Das ist Mist.
Guck mal.
Kriegst sogar hier.
Bei 299 ist wirklich nicht übel, ne?
Ach, mir der bei Ebay irgendwelche komischen...
Ja.
Naja.
Ja, vor der KI-Geschichte war das alles deutlich billiger.
Du hast vor KI, also bevor das losgegangen ist mit der Hardware-Knappheit,
konntest du ECC SO-DIMM DDR5 RAM kaufen für 200 Euro oder so.
Für 198, 96 Gig waren es glaube ich und mittlerweile sind es bei 700 Euro.
Das ist echt nicht mehr normal.
Ich habe heute mit einem unserer Storage-Leute gesprochen,
ob wir in der Versicherung betroffen sind von den Hardwarepreisen und Storage-Knappheit und so.
Die haben gesagt, nee, nee, die bezahlen alles.
Das einzige Problem, was sie haben, sind Lieferzeiten, die teilweise nicht eingehalten werden.
Also sogar bei uns schlägt es sich durch.
Preis ist denen egal, die haben anscheinend genug Geld.
Aber Lieferzeiten macht denen mehr zu schaffen.
Wobei ich halt auch denke, dass die Lieferzeiten halt nicht direkt sind für
Hersteller schickt Festplatte an die Versicherung
Sondern man hat irgendeinen Supportvertrag mit dem Hersteller, der dann zum Festplattenhersteller geht
Und man im Endeffekt dann sogar sagen könnte
Ey, guck mal hier, SLA verletzt, ist nicht innerhalb von 48 Stunden da oder sowas
Da haben die Hersteller halt ziemlich gelitten aktuell
Wenn die keine Festplatten kriegen, kriegen sie halt keine Festplatten
So, jetzt haben wir geupdatet
gucken wir hier ob es da noch irgendwelche package updates gibt no pass so wisst ihr
um jetzt mal hier old geht's zu sein ich glaube meine erste gaming so richtig die ich mir explizit
für gaming gekauft habe gpu war eine elsa eraser 2 mit tnt 1 dieses ding hier passiv gekühlt noch
da habe ich lüfter drauf gemacht damals weil die zwei geworden ist oder mit zwei guter vga stecker
und ich glaube die hat damals irgendwas um 200 markt oder so gekostet 200 250 mark das war damals
die beste grafikkarte dies gegeben hat paru weil ich so an die gewöhnt bin gibt keinen
keinen bock auf paru ja also das war beste grafikkarte damals 250 mark und das müsste
so gewesen sein 1998 rum seit wann ist max auf cash ios und wieso also der
grund ist folgender ich bin auf cash ios erstens weil es gehypt ist und zweitens
weil ich nicht mehr auf einer vm bin sondern auf einer echten hardware linux
kiste nämlich auf einem beelink mini pc sr 7 und da dachte ich mir wenn man schon so was machen
dann können wir auch cash us hype plus kde machen mit wayland weil ich gehe halt davon aus dass x11
immer weiter an support wird immer weiter aus gefasst wird überall das heißt jetzt ist eigentlich
eine ganz gute zeit auch wenn ich mich teilweise übelst aufregend über wayland nicht dass ich mich
über X nicht aufrege, ne?
Ist das, glaube ich, jetzt eines der
besten Zeitpunkte dafür gewesen.
Und das Wichtigste,
Pitta, Pitta, Pitta, Pitta, das Wichtigste, guck mal hier.
Siehst du das hier?
Endlich! Wobbly Windows
Effekt wieder. Guckt euch, guckt es dir an.
Ist das nicht nice? Und das Beste
ist, das seht ihr nicht, aber für mich das
Beste ist, 240
Hertz Wobble.
Das heißt, für mich ist das hier gestochen
scharf, während es wobbelt. Für euch nicht.
Es sind Wubblos Windows, ja.
Das stimmt mit Wayland.
So, so sieht's aus.
Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft.
Ja, man kann nicht alles haben.
Wenn ich mit 240 Hertz streamen würde,
gäbe es wieder mit der Bandbreite Probleme,
weil die musste dann natürlich hoch machen.
Wobei ich mir selbst mal gar nicht sicher bin,
unterstützt Twitch überhaupt?
Kann Twitch überhaupt
120 Hertz Streams?
Geht das überhaupt?
Live 120 FPS Streams.
120 Hertz Streams.
Gibt keine.
Okay.
120 FPS Streams?
Äh.
Im Leben sind das keine 120 FPS Streams.
Guck mal der.
720p, 120 FPS.
Gucken wir mal, ob das nicht gelogen ist.
Ne, 60.
Guck mal.
Sind nur 60 FPS.
Kann man das einstellen überhaupt?
äh, Qualität, ne, geht nicht
jeder kann reinschreiben, was er will, ja, aber ist halt doch ein bisschen blöd, ne
so, dann loggen wir uns mal auf das NAS ein, hier sind wir
äh, warte mal, SSH, Rutge
wobei so oft wie ich mich da heute wahrscheinlich drauf einloggen muss, Copy ID
Moment, ich hab noch keine, wait a minute, ich hab hier noch keine SSH
was ist das?
Ich habe noch keine SSH-Keys generiert.
SSH-Keygen.
Äh, Chatgear.
E.
ED25519.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen ED25519 und ED25519-SK?
What is the minus SK ending for SSH-Keys?
Fido.
Ah, für Sticks.
Oder? Ja, ja, für so Token-Sticks.
Das ist GPU-abhängig, was denn?
Ich finde das übrigens bei Chatterino sehr nice, dass man hier so ein History-Ding hat, ja.
Wenn meine RTX-GPU Wayland unterstützen würde, würde ich auch umsteigen.
Das ist GPU-abhängig.
Naja, das läuft schon unter Linux, aber Nvidia hat massive Treiberprobleme unter Linux.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die letzten Monate besser geworden ist oder nicht.
Zumindest war das so, dass teilweise Nvidia performance-mäßig 50% schlechter war als unter Windows.
Wir haben auch Keys auf der Arbeit.
Die liegen bei mir im Spind rum und keiner will sie irgendwie haben.
Die wurden mir fürs Projekt bestellt
Dann haben die mir drei Stück davon gegeben
Und haben gesagt, ah ja
Falls wir hier mal so eine
So eine Offline-Kiste mit aufbauen
Dann brauchen wir die Sticks
Und ich kann ja mal damit ein bisschen ausprobieren
Hab ich ein bisschen damit ausprobiert
Und seitdem wollte die nie wieder jemand haben
Seitdem liegen die bei mir im Spind
Hast du schon
Nee, hab ich immer noch nicht
Sag mal, Sparky, weil du da so oft nachfragst
Ist das von dir?
Das fände ich enorm pock, wenn das von dir ist.
Das hier ne?
CacheOS.
Yes, yes, yes
Das stimmt, Akkulaufzeit ist
nicht, also für mobile Sachen
ja, Akkulaufzeit
war schon immer nicht so geil mit Linux
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es jetzt ist
Ob das vielleicht besser geworden ist
Aber wenn du sagst, es sackt immer noch
Dann ist das wahrscheinlich auch so
So, ups, sehr schlau Max
Erstmal Terminal geclosed
Quit
Äh, warum habe ich jetzt nochmal die ID kopiert?
Weil
So, da sind wir, Chatkill
Ich lösche mal meine Bash-History
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, warum
Aber wer weiß
Ja
Nicht, dass ich jetzt hier MonkaToss-Sachen
Oder der ist ja noch gar nichts drauf
Ich kann da eigentlich nichts leaken
So, da sind wir auf meinem Nass
Für alle, die es nicht mitbekommen haben
Guckte mal her
Mittlerweile ist die
Netzwerkkarte richtig schnell
CD Desktop
Wir machen jetzt ein iPerf
Test
iPerf
So, in die eine Richtung iPerf
Bam, bam, bam
9,5
9,4 Gigabits pro Sekunde
Also eigentlich am Limit
Von dem was 10 Gig hergibt
Mehr geht da nicht
Und in die andere Richtung
haben wir ja so 99,1 gigabits pro sekunde also das ist sehr schnell mittlerweile und wer sich
jetzt fragt was ich gemacht habe erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch dran dass ich echt probleme
mit der netzwerkkarte hatte also das rätsel ist lösung das ordentlich auf die reihe zu bekommen
mit der netzwerkkarte war man braucht einen hat reiber vom hersteller und zwar habe ich auf github
habe was gefunden, da hat einer schon
DKMS-Configs dafür generiert.
DKMS sind Kernel-Module,
die automatisch immer neu gebaut
werden, wenn der Kernel geupdatet wird.
Das heißt, es ist quasi,
muss ich nicht jedes Mal meinen Netzwerktreiber neu kompilieren.
Dann habe ich mir
den aktuellen Realtek-Treiber runtergeladen,
hier reingepackt,
beziehungsweise nochmal kontrolliert, ob das wirklich
der aktuelle Realtek-Treiber ist.
Dann musste ich in das
Make-File vom Realtek-Treiber
ist das Gigabit
oder gibi bit alter fragt mich nicht auf das ist das ist das ist glaube ich wirklich gigabit chat
oder das ist gigabit das ist 1000 1000 gb gb oder gibi sind glaube ich 1024 und das sind echte gigabit
So.
Und was ich dann machen musste ist, ich muss in das Makefile von meinem Netzwerktreiber gehen.
Das Jahr des Linux-Desktops ist hier.
Und ich musste das Power-Management von der Netzwerkkarte disablen.
Unterm Strich macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob das Enabled oder Disabled ist.
Ich habe hier so ein Messgerät dran.
Das Ding verbraucht gerade aktuell, lasst mich mal drauf gucken, 14,6 Watt, 13,9 Watt, 15, 14,6, 14,2, 14, 13,9, also 14.
Um die 14 Watt braucht das Ding gerade idle.
Was echt okay ist. Ich meine, da stecken drei SSDs schon einmal drin und eine 10 Gig Onboard-Netzwerkkarte.
Das ist nicht verkehrt. Also 14 Watt idle ist vollkommen fein.
Moin Max, was denkst du, was der optimale Tag ist für den Teilzeit-Tag?
Oder was hast du geschrieben?
Was denkst du, ist der optimale Tag sich den Teilzeit-Tag, Montag,
mitten in der Woche oder am Anfang, mach es am Anfang, Montag.
Montag ist der beste Teilzeit-Tag.
Mitten in der Woche ist nichts, du willst es am Stück haben.
Weil du darfst nicht vergessen, ein Tag mehr frei bedeutet auch automatisch ein Tag weniger arbeiten.
und am Stück ist es besser, egal
ob länger frei oder weniger arbeiten
oder halt arbeiten am Stück dann, ja
das ist besser, nach Montag
weil, ganz einfach
Montag
kommen die Leute alle aus dem Wochenende
sind super motiviert, wenn es irgendwelche
Fehler gibt, muss sie die Montags fixen
Montag gehen sie alle auf den Keks
Freitags
passiert eh nix, weil Freitags sind sie geistig
schon alle im Wochenende
Montag ist der beste Tag
was andere Möglichkeit gibt es ja nicht
Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, mitten in der Woche taucht nichts
ne Montag, also ich kann das auch
nur empfehlen
ja
Montag ist das Beste
ja, das klingt so banal
ein Tag mehr frei gleich ein Tag weniger arbeiten
das klingt so banal, aber das verschiebt
das ganz schön, überleg dir mal
du hättest ein Tag noch mehr frei
schon würdest du quasi, hättest du mehr
frei in der Woche, als du arbeiten würdest.
Man sieht das immer sonst nur so einseitig.
So nach dem Motto, ja, ein Tag mehr frei.
Und im Kopf denkt man sich, ja, das heißt
ja dann trotzdem fünf Tage, stimmt ja nicht.
Es ist wirklich ein Tag mehr frei, ein Tag weniger
arbeiten.
Wo arbeitest du?
Ich arbeite in der Versicherung.
Ja, genau.
Genau, das meint echt viel aus.
Also ich kann das übrigens generell
wenn man sich das irgendwie auch eine andere Weise finanziell leisten kann,
sehr empfehlen, Teilzeit zu arbeiten und den freien Tag zu machen.
Beste Kombination.
Und so viel weniger Geld ist es jetzt auch wieder nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, so krass ist es jetzt auch wieder nicht.
gerade durch die Teilzeit
und dass ich relativ wenig
Rufbereitschaft gerade mache und sowas.
Das hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich kann dir sagen,
nee, mach mal, mach mal, Anna,
wir müssen jetzt Nassstelz machen, sonst wird das
wieder nix.
Dem Merz, dem gefällt einiges nicht.
Ich habe auch, ich habe in den News irgendwie gelesen, der mag das auch nicht, wenn man ihn so mit langer Nase nennt und sowas.
Aber das wurde eingestellt mittlerweile.
Ich finde das übrigens ein komplettes Unding, ne?
Dass da einfach random Leute angezeigt werden.
Na, einen Tag weniger ist halt ein Fünftel weniger Geld gekriegt.
Ja, ja, ja, das ist auf dem Papier so, aber du bezahlst ja auch ein bisschen weniger Steuern.
Das heißt, es ist nicht ganz ein Fünftel weniger.
Aber im Prinzip hast du recht.
Ja, das macht enorm viel aus.
So Chat, falls ich irgendwas überlesen habe, dann haut einfach nochmal in den Chat mit Ed Wobblos dabei.
Wir gucken uns jetzt mal hier was an mit Samba und wie schnell wir sind.
Also, was ich jetzt erstmal machen will.
Also ihr habt gesehen, Netzwerkverbindung, alles richtig schön schnell und nice.
So.
Ich zeige das hier nochmal.
Wir können übrigens mal noch einen iPerf machen.
bi-directional
können wir glaube ich noch machen.
Also wenn man gleichzeitig
10 Gig überträgt, dann wird es halt
bisschen weniger, okay.
Aber ist immer noch ziemlich gut.
Aber damit dürfte die Netzwerkkarte jetzt auch richtig am Limit laufen.
Gerade.
Also mit 10 Gigabit
Full Duplex in beide Richtungen.
Das ist aber wirklich
nicht schlecht, ja.
Was es da durchkriegt.
Das macht ja keiner.
Bei welchem Anwendungs...
Guck mal, 459 Retries, das ist halt nix.
Ich meine, es dürften auch gerne 0 sein, aber ich glaube, die Netzwerkkarte ist halt einfach am Limit.
So, also seht, gibt ordentlich Wumms übers Netzwerk.
Jetzt probieren wir mal, wie schnell wir das Ganze hinbekommen übers Netzlaufwerk.
Was ich jetzt probieren will, also mein Plan ist folgender.
Ups, äh.
Äh, Base-T, also Kupfer, ja.
Es ist, also der Traffic läuft gerade so.
Das ist eine Netzwerkkarte mit einem ganz normalen RJ45 Stecker.
Das geht an einen 10 Gig Switch.
Der 10 Gig Switch hat aber nur SFP Plus.
Da steckt aktuell ein Modul drin, der SFP Plus auf RJ45.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist es eine SFP Plus Netzwerkkarte mit einem 5 Meter Direct Attach Kabel.
Wie viele Meter? Zwei. Also vom Switch zum Last sind es ungefähr zwei Meter. Vom Desktop-Rechner, wo ich das hier ausprobiere, zum Switch sind es ungefähr fünf Meter.
und
ne, es ist kein
Cat 8 Kabel, aber bei der Entfernung
brauchst du auch kein Cat 8 Kabel.
Ich glaube, es ist, was ist es, wahrscheinlich ein Cat 6 Kabel
oder so, irgendein olles Kabel, was
noch da ist. Aber kein
super schlechtes, aber
bei der Entfernung,
da geht es wahrscheinlich sogar easy über
ein Cat 5 Kabel, auch wenn das nicht
offiziell spezifiziert ist.
So, also mein Plan ist folgender.
Ich installiere mir jetzt eine VM.
Erstmal meine Disk decrypten.
Stopp, den brauchen wir nicht.
Ich installiere mir jetzt eine VM mit Open Media Vault.
Ich will zwei Sachen, zwei Szenarios will ich testen.
Einmal VM mit Open Media Vault.
Mal gucken, wie schnell es ist.
und dann einen Debian-Container mit Samba von Hand installiert und gucken, wie schnell es ist.
Wenn das funktioniert, will ich davor noch ein Merger-FS pappen,
weil damit kann ich quasi einen Write-Cache bauen.
Dann habe ich da eine Kombination aus HDDs plus SSDs als Write-Cache.
Und einmal nachts schiebe ich dann die Daten von der SSD auf die HDD oder einmal in der Stunde oder whatever.
Ja, muss ich mal gucken.
Eine Sache, die mich hier bei diesem
Linux-Setup noch ein bisschen nervt, ist,
wie stellt man denn
ein diese
Keyboard,
also diese
Wiederholrate,
Key-Repeat, genau.
Machen wir mal hier 300.
Ja, das ist gut.
Das ist schon besser.
Ich bin das nämlich gewohnt, dass das ein bisschen schneller ist.
Ich krieg da immer Anfälle, wenn ich da ewig warten muss.
Ja, das ist gut.
Ja.
Exzellent.
Gehen wir mal zu.
Also, auf geht's.
Dann machen wir mal Proxmox auf.
2.51.
Was? 1.51.
Port. Oh, Proxmox-Port, Leute.
80.
30 oder irgendwie sowas.
8006 ist es, oder?
8006.
Eben in dem Moment, wo ich es getippt habe, ist es mir eingefallen.
Root.
So, Proxmox stellt es am Start.
Also, wir haben unser Paypal noch am Start.
Ich habe eine Docploy mittlerweile am Start zum Ausprobieren.
warum kein bookmark weil ich auf der kiste noch nirgendwo eingeloggt war dns
dns gibt es für temporäre aufbauten noch nicht wobei doch ich hab ich habe sogar
den dns eintrag für die doch bleukiste aber nicht für das box box den das
bekommt also was sie pvp punkt irgend etwas so dann würde ich sagen installieren
mal Open Media Vault.
Also,
wo war das jetzt hier? Create neue VM.
Name. Open Media Vault.
Next.
Kein ISO.
Äh, QEMU Agent.
Äh,
ähm,
Next.
Disk ist okay.
CPU-Cores, ja 5 oder so müsste ja reichen
Memory
Ja, kriegt schon ein bisschen RAM das Ding, hä?
8 Gig
Netzwerk, Wirt.io
Firewall, können wir ausschalten, brauchen wir nicht
Leider hat die Netzwerkkarte kein SAIOV
SAIOV wäre wirklich noch so das Sahnehäubchen bei der Hardware-Auswahl gewesen
Wisst ihr, was SRIOV ist?
Oder soll ich es kurz erklären?
Hypervisor und Nass auf demselben Haus.
Ah ja, warum nicht?
Warum nicht?
Warum soll ich mehr Strom verbrauchen, als notwendig?
Ich meine, ich schreibe ja nicht von Proxmox irgendwie über das Nass auf die Platten oder so komisches zu.
also es also fangen wir mal anders an ich versuche es mal ohne wikipedia zu erklären bringt ja auch
nichts wenn ich euch das vorlese also es sei uv ihr wisst ja wahrscheinlich was pc pass through
ist also du kannst zum beispiel ein pc gerät durchreichen in eine vm so du kannst aber in
der regel ein pc gerät nur einmal durchreichen an eine vm was bei geräten wie netzwerkkarten
ziemlich doof ist, weil dein Host braucht die Netzwerkkarte und alle VMs brauchen potenziell
die Netzwerkkarte.
Ja, was man dann normalerweise macht ist, so wie das Proxmox auch macht, man benutzt
eine virtuelle Netzwerkkarte, die dann bei Linux an der Bridge hängt und das Netzwerkzeug
mehr oder weniger in Software passiert.
Das ist natürlich performance-technisch nicht so geil.
Bei einer fetten Kiste geht es trotzdem, aber ist performance-technisch nicht so geil.
Ja und vielleicht kitzelt man auch nicht das allerletzte Stück an Bandbreite in der VM raus.
So, dann gibt es sowas wie SAIOV.
SAIOV gibt es meines Wissens nach hauptsächlich bei Netzwerkkarten und bei Grafikkarten.
Und das erlaubt es, eine Netzwerkkarte an mehrere VMs durchzureichen als PCI-Gerät.
Also SAIOV ist nochmal so eine Virtualisierungsschicht über der Netzwerkhardware,
Netzwerk-Hardware, die aus einer physischen Netzwerk-Karte quasi 16 PCI-Express-Geräte, 16 virtuelle PCI-Express-Geräte macht, die du dann an VMs durchreichen kannst.
Das heißt, die VM denkt, du hast eine Netzwerk-Karte bei PCI-Express-Paths durchgereicht.
In Wirklichkeit ist es nur das SAE-OV-Device, aber du hast dann die volle Performance von einer Netzwerk-Karte, wie wenn es ein PCI-Gerät wäre.
Da kannst du nochmal so die letzte Latency und Bandbreite dann rauskitzeln.
Leider hat diese VM, hat diese Netzwerkkarte, das ist ein billiger Realtek R8127, der hat sowas nicht.
Aber das wäre wirklich noch so Sahnehäubchen drauf gewesen, hätte Minisforum hier eine SAEUV-hege Netzwerkkarte draufgepappt.
die Pro-Version von dem NAS, die hat glaube ich
irgendeinen Aquantik-Chip, der
glaube ich, SRIOV
kann, das Ding ist
nur, das NAS hat wahrscheinlich
einen defekten SATA-Controller,
die Pro-Version und
ist überhaupt
nicht stromsparend.
So, deswegen, das ist SRIOV.
SRIOV gibt es auch bei Grafikkarten,
Grafikkarten durchreichen an VMs, dass man quasi
eine Grafikkarte an mehrere VMs durchreichen kann.
Eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache,
Deswegen habe ich überlegt,
ob ich nicht,
weil das Ding hat auch einen PC-Express-Slot.
Das NAS ist wirklich enorm pock.
Also das ist das hier.
N5 Luft.
Eigentlich heißt es N5R.
Aber Minis Forum übersetzt das witzigerweise
manchmal mit N5 Luft,
weil die einfach irgendwelche komischen...
Übrigens, dass da AI drinne steht,
könnt ihr ignorieren.
Das ist ein ganz normales NAS-Hardware.
Hat absolut gar nichts mit AI zu tun.
Ich glaube, die schreiben da einfach nur AI drauf, weil AI sich gut anhört.
Teil des die Performance, hab gelesen, dass bei GPU, SAIOV wird das VRAM geteilt, zum Beispiel 16 GB auf 4 GB.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist so.
Ich habe aber mit SAIOV und GPUs gar keine Erfahrung.
Aber ich glaube, das ist so, was du sagst.
Wie viel RAM hast du verbaut?
32 Gig.
Von den 32 Gig
hat die Grafikkarte
2 Gig und das restliche
System hat 30 Gig.
Das liegt aber auch einfach nur da dran,
weil ich keinen Bock habe, mir neuen RAM zu
kaufen. Ich hatte noch 32
Gig SO. Heißt das
eigentlich SO-DIMM oder S0-DIMM?
Also die kleinen RAM-Riegel.
Da hatte ich noch 32 Gig hier
und da habe ich mir gedacht, ey komm, warum willst du
mehr RAM? Mehr brauchst du eh nicht. 32 Gig
ist vollkommen fein.
So.
Das ist das Ding. Und das Teil hat, was ich halt mega finde,
das Teil hat wirklich noch
ein PCI-Express-Socket da drinnen.
Guck mal hier.
Die haben noch ein PCI-16-File.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass da mit 16 Lanes
angebunden ist.
PCI-Express-Slot.
Da habe ich mir schon überlegt,
wenn ich den nicht brauche, weil ich...
Ich meine, die Standardbestückung ist vollkommen
fein, ja.
Kommt da wieder Unraid drauf, beziehungsweise
ein alter Server End of Life? Na, End of Life
ist der vom Hersteller höchstwahrscheinlich schon.
Aber
den werde ich ausmustern.
Den werde ich nicht mehr behalten.
Da kommt wahrscheinlich kein
Unraid drauf, sondern Proxmox.
Ich bin nie
so richtig happy gewesen mit Unraid.
Vielleicht
bin ich happy mit Proxmox, müssen wir mal gucken.
So, und was ich mir jetzt halt überlegt habe, weil das Ding hat halt standardmäßig 5 Ports für Festplatten und SSDs und 3 interne NVMe SSDs und einen internen für die ganzen Android-Enjoyer, einen internen USB 3.2 Stecker und ich brauche hier kein PCI Express nochmal für, keine Ahnung, 5 NVMe SSDs oder sowas.
ich habe mir überlegt vielleicht mache ich da doch aber ein bisschen aktuellere 10 gig netzwerkkarte
rein ob media wall bin ich mir noch nicht sicher ich installiere jetzt erstmal media
wollen und guck mal wie gut das performt in der vm mal gucken wenn ich kommt da ein
Debian LXT Container drauf mit Samba
von Hand installiert und gut ist.
Ja.
Ich hab hier noch
eine alte
X500
also eine
14 Jahre alt 10 Gig Netzwerkkarte
hab ich hier noch. Also ich hab mehrere 10 Gig Netzwerkkarten,
aber mit der
Melanox Karte haben wir ja das letzte Mal
schon schlechte Erfahrungen
gemacht.
Ich hab noch so ein Ding hier rumfliegen.
ein ganz altes sagt die dinger sind 14 jahre alt im kern diese karten die können aber glaube ich
auch es sei uv vielleicht stöpsel ich die mal rein und guckt wie viel strom die zieht aber
ich glaube ich kaufe mir ein bisschen modernere netzwerkkarte so irgendwas was dann halt nicht
30 euro kostet sondern 60 euro hat auch gebraucht und dann gucken wir mal weil weil es für die vms
wäre schon richtig nice bei der Netzwerkkarte.
Nicht, dass man es so ein bisschen
braucht, ja. Von der Performance reicht
die Kiste. Ich meine, das Ding hat,
guckt euch das mal an, ne. Das hat richtig
Wumms.
Das Ding hat, guck mal hier, das sind die
CPU-Kerne.
Das hat 8 Kerne, 16 Threads.
Also, das Ding hat Rechenleistung
echt richtig krass
für eine NAS, ja.
Gerade mal, wenn man es
mit den billigen Synology-Dingern oder so vergleicht.
Acht Kerne, 16 Cores.
Äh, nicht 16 Cores.
Acht Kerne, 16 Cores, Alter.
Acht Kerne, also acht Cores, 16 Threads.
Ist schon echt nicht übel.
Ich glaube, die Pro-Variante hat, glaube ich, sogar 32.
Aber die Synology-Dinger haben keine...
keine schnelle Hardware drin.
Jonas, Jonas, das letzte Mal, wo ich mir Jonas
eingeguckt habe, hat mir nicht so gut gefallen.
Aber nachdem ich ja schon ein bisschen Interesse dran
habe, da Containerkram drauf laufen
zu lassen und
VMs drauf laufen zu lassen, ist glaube ich
Proxmox für mich der bessere Ansatz.
Ja, ich mache halt so
50-50. 50% Nass,
50% Virtualisierung und
Gebastel. Das heißt, ich glaube, Proxmox
ist nicht verkehrt.
Android als Host
also das letzte mal wo ich Android ausprobiert habe da hat mir die containerisierung und
virtualisierungsgeschichte über Android überhaupt nicht gefallen ich habe einen Ugreen NAS
ich habe einen Ugreen NAS gekauft das gucken wir uns im stream übrigens auch noch an das heißt wenn ihr
dabei sein wollt ne ich muss immer ein bisschen sellout machen follow follow ich habe in 4800
plus habe ich hier von ukraine und ein 4800 pro von ukraine die sind aber cpu technisch deutlich
schlechter ausgestattet als das mini forum dass wir haben kein pc express und die verbrauchen
eitel ein bisschen mehr das 4800 plus verbraucht ungefähr 20 22 watt mit der bestückung die ich
jetzt habe versus also mit drei nvm ssds und 10 gig link und das mini forum 14
also ist ist schon ein bisserl mehr dass das 4800 pro weiß ich nicht das habe ich
nicht ausgepackt ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher ob ich das ausparken oder
ob ich sie wieder zurück schicke
potea mag ich nicht doch hier ist ganz nice ja
also ich bin ich werde mir jetzt erst mal das ganze mit box angucken willst
du starten über box auf die plan also mein plan ist folgendes spatzgranate
Mein plan ist folgendes der fiat mit dem geht es gut da steht im hof und
Champs so vor sich hin
Hast du eigentlich inzwischen drei mal 24 terabyte hdds gekauft nein ich habe einmal
26 terabyte hdd gekauft zum schucken chat habt ihr schon mal eine hdd geschuckt
Das war meine nächste woche nächste woche wird hier
Seagate Desktop Expansion Amazon.
Nächste Woche wird...
Ah, heute mal wieder in Berlin. Nice.
Nächste Woche wird das Ding hier geschuckt on stream.
Mal gucken, ob das taugt.
Dann wird die Festplatte ausgebaut.
Weil, kostet nur 499 Euro.
und eine 26TB
Platte so, so zum
einen kostet 700€.
Oder so in dem Dreh.
Das Ugreen
DXP6800
ist nice von der
Hardware, verbraucht aber richtig
viel Strom im Idle. Ich habe irgendwas um 40W
gelesen. 40W Idle ist schon ordentlich.
Aber warum ist das so?
Weiß ich, musst du Sie Geld fragen.
Hast du Mini-PC Empfehlungen?
Also ich kann zwei Mini-PCs empfehlen,
die sind aber beide nicht mehr top aktuell.
Da müsst ihr gucken, ob es eine neue Version
von gibt. Also, ich kann einmal
hier den da empfehlen.
Den finde ich sehr nice.
Den habe ich am Start. Habe ich auch gerade ein Video zu gemacht.
Den fand ich gut.
Da gibt es höchstwahrscheinlich, guck mal, wie günstig
der refurbished ist. Kek weh.
Und der ist gar nicht schlecht. Guck.
Da ist ein
Ryzen-Dings. Gut, da muss man
natürlich noch RAM und SSD. Kostet schon noch ein bisschen mehr.
Also, den finde ich gut.
Gibt bestimmt mittlerweile neuere Versionen davon.
Aber so als Gaming-Emulator-Plattform und sowas ist der mega.
Und wen ich auch empfehlen kann, da gibt es aber bestimmt auch einen neueren von.
Das ist der, den ich hier gerade benutze.
Da, wo ich hier gerade mal Linux drauflaufen habe, den finde ich eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Das einzig Dumme an dem ist die Farbe.
Die Farbe sackt richtig.
Das sieht mega hässlich aus, das Ding.
Ganz ehrlich, mir würde das Ding besser gefallen, ich würde die komplette Hardware da raus schucken
und das Gehäuse wegschmeißen, ja, die Hardware sieht besser aus als das Gehäuse.
So, jetzt war ich ja super krass sidetracked, wir wollten eigentlich ja Zeug ins Hild.
Ach ja, Frage zu hier, Dings, ähm.
zu der frage wie ich das machen will also ich mein plan ist folgendes ich will erst mal jetzt
zum testen eine open media wort in der vm installieren und dann werde ich meine main
ZFS RAID 1 was über zwei NVMe SSDs läuft werde ich per BIT.IO FS in den Open Media Wall mappen
und mal gucken wie schnell das ganze ist. Das machen wir jetzt auch. Wenn das schnell ist oder
vielleicht nicht so zufriedenstellend ist dann mache ich mir einen LXC Container und installiere
wir da debian selbst drauf mal gucken mal gucken warum ist das pain das klingt
eigentlich ganz gut lösung so also dann wollen wir doch mal network erstellen
jetzt schauen wir mal dass jetzt hat das ding die id 100 wobei alt 100 für das
nass ist schon okay.
So ein Basic-Ding. So, jetzt
müssen wir mal kurz gucken. Muss ich noch irgendwas
in den Options machen?
Poemo
Guest Agent habe ich eingestellt.
Warum nicht einfach den Controller oder
die Festplatte durchreichen?
Weil ich die Festplatte,
äh, nee, nicht die Festplatte, weil ich die
SSDs in meinem Box-Mock brauche.
Da kommen ja meine ganzen, da sind ja mal
laufen ja meine ganzen VMs drauf. Guck hier.
ZFS Pool Status.
Ja, wenn man es richtig schreibt.
Ich habe hier ein Mirror.
Okay, bevor jetzt jemand sagt, Max, guck mal hier,
du verschenkst doch hier einen Terabyte.
Ich weiß.
Ich weiß,
dass ich einen Terabyte verschenke.
Aber der Grund, warum ich einen Terabyte
verschenke, also ich verschenke einen Terabyte, weil ich
einen 2 Terabyte oder
1 Terabyte SSD im RAID 1 habe.
Ich weiß, aber
der Grund, warum ich das Terabyte
verschenke, ist zum Geld sparen.
Ich wollte mir nicht eine 2 Terabyte SSD
kaufen, wenn ich eine 2 Terabyte und eine 1 Terabyte
SSD noch daheim liegen habe.
Ja.
Und ich reiche das nicht durch, weil hierauf
laufen meine VMs in Proxmox.
Also macht ja keinen Sinn,
das durchzureichen.
Externe Backups?
Meinst du auf irgendeinem Cloud-Laufwerk oder so?
Oder was meinst du?
Also habe ich aktuell nicht.
Das einzige, was ich habe, ist...
Ich habe ein...
Offside-Backup für Arme.
Ich habe eine Platte...
...gespiegelt...
Die legt hinten im Gartenhäuschen.
Also, die kommt rein, kriegt einen Air-Sync und kommt ins Gartenhäuschen.
Also, wenn das Haus abfackelt, sollte die safe sein.
Warum nicht auf der Arbeit?
RF-Programmer, soll ich dir mal was sagen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Da bin ich noch gar nicht drauf gekommen.
Ich habe ja einen Spind auf der Arbeit.
Da könnte ich eigentlich einfach ein Offside-Backup mir in den Spind legen.
Die Dinger sind ja eh komplett verschlüsselt.
Selbst wenn das zufällig da mal einer klauen sollte, weil der Spind kaputt ist oder so, kann ja nichts passieren.
Also es ist eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee, bei mir auf der Arbeit was in den Spind zu legen.
Finde ich gut. Ja.
Gute Idee.
Exzellent.
Das ist der High IQ.
Die Subscriptions haben sich schon wieder bezahlt gemacht, ja.
Chat, ich muss mal kurz meine Pillen nehmen.
Battlefield 3?
Alter, das ist ja richtig, richtig alt.
Grinch, lass mich raten.
Du warst damals 13-jähriges Call-of-Duty-Kind.
So wie 90% des Chats irgendwie
Sag nicht ich
Sag der Chat von sich selbst
Ja
Sag nicht ich
17 sogar
Ich bin mittlerweile
Ich werde dieses Jahr 42
keck wait.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir
auch mal ein bisschen weiter machen hier.
Ich hab, glaube ich, nur bis
19.40 Uhr oder so bezeichnet.
Also hier, Open Media Vault.
Muss ich hier noch irgendwas einstellen?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich kann euch was zeigen. Chat.
Chat, passt mal auf. Ich hab's
gefixt. Ich hab PXE-Boot
gefixt für
für Proxmox.
Guck mal, PXE-Boot ist fixt.
ich kann jetzt px e boot machen über proxmox seht ihr das massive pxe boot
übrigens ki katzenbild ja soll ich euch zeigen wie ich wie ich das gefixt war
was was war es naja das problem war ja dass proxmox selbst über ipxe gebootet
hat und ich habe einen check drin wenn ipxe kommt dann soll er ipxe hier boot
menü ausliefern da verwende ich allerdings sachen drin die das ipx mit dem box standardmäßig kommt
nicht kann nämlich dass box box xp xp kann keine hintergrundbilder und ganz ehrlich ohne katzen
hintergrund boot bild geht das ganze nicht ich kann euch zeigen wie es gefixt habe wie geht es
eigentlich da eine katze meine katze lebt schon seit zweieinhalb jahren oder so nicht mehr setke
massive set ich kann euch ich kann euch zeigen wie ich das gefixt haben also gehen wir mal auf
ein raspberry pi das ist gar nicht der raspberry pi ich kann nur baller das ist das ist mein router
Moment mal, Raspberry Pi, was habe ich da für einen User?
Max bestimmt, hä?
Ja, hat aber Glück gehabt hier.
Der PXE Champ.
Also was ich gemacht habe, ist folgendes.
Ich habe hier
TFDP
Boot IPXE.
Ich habe hier einen Check reingebaut. Guckt mal.
IPXE Check.
Also.
Der versucht, die Konsole
auf diese Auflösung zu setzen.
Wenn das funktioniert,
dann macht er ganz normal
weiter. Wenn das
nicht funktioniert,
also Auflösung setzen nicht
funktioniert, heißt, es ist ein
IPXE, der kein
ähm,
Buildersupport hat.
Wenn es ein IPXE ist, der kein
Buildersupport hat, dann macht er
Go to Chain, Chain,
checkt,
ist die Plattform, über die gebootet wird.
EFI oder BIOS Boot.
Wenn es EFI ist,
go to EFI. Wenn es BIOS ist, go to BIOS.
Boot EFI
lädt von meinem TFTP-Server
ein Hintergrund
Image-fähiges
IPXE runter und Chainbooted
da rein. Wenn es BIOS ist,
geht er zu meinem TFTP-Server
und lädt ein
IPXE Hintergrund
Bildfähiges
BIOS Boot Image runter und Chainbooted
da rein und dann macht er weiter so habe ich das gefix und das hier was ihr hier seht ist im
endeffekt dass sie das boot menü hier so was wir jetzt hier wollen in dem boot menü ist wir wollen
ob media volt installieren das geht nicht direkt über meine lokalen images da muss ich über net
boot xyz gehen es geht nur die einzige möglichkeit ist zu machen in pxe in diesem ipx script ist per
go to andere sachen gehen nicht gibt es nicht mehr fall kann man nicht sagen geht nicht gibt
es nicht das geht einfach nicht hat man dann gelitten linux network installs haben wir hier
open media world gibt es das hier überhaupt drin live cds open media chat es gibt kein
open media world in netboot xyz wirklich nett oder bin ich einfach nur oder bin ich einfach
zu blind wie es gibt es momentan open media world netboot xyz das gibt es
wirklich nicht wirklich das gibt es echt nicht
ok das geht anscheinend nicht ok ich muss dann muss mir wirklich dass sie so
jetzt runterladen.
O-M-G.
Was hältst du eigentlich von den
PvE-Helper-Skripts? Nix.
Ich will wissen, was bei mir läuft
lokal und nicht, was in irgendwelchen Skripts,
die ich nicht gelesen habe, ausgeführt wird.
Das einzige Proxmox-Skript,
was ich verwende, ist dieses Menü-Ding
hier. Für so ein paar kleine
Sachen. Aber ansonsten
nix.
Ich weiß, dass ich
die URL in den Boxbox reinkopieren kann, aber ich zeige dir
jetzt auch gleich, warum ich das nicht mache.
Wo muss denn das hin?
Lib?
Wo muss denn die Isus hin?
Hier.
LibVZ
Images?
Da müssen die, glaube ich, hin.
Nicht ganz sicher,
aber ich glaube schon.
So, ich zeig dir jetzt auch, warum ich das nicht über das Proxmox Webinterface mache.
Deswegen, weil manchmal die Downloads abfuck langsam sind und du weißt nicht, was Sache ist.
Und du musst nämlich über Southforge, musst du die Downloads ein paar Mal neu starten, in der Hoffnung, dass du schnell ein Download-Mirror erwischst.
Guck.
Und das kannst du nicht über das Webinterface machen, deswegen mach ich es über die Konsole.
Es hat schon seinen Sinn, Chat.
Klingt zwar manchmal so planlos
Aber manchmal, selten gebe ich zu
Ja, aber manchmal denke ich mir was bei
Das ist nicht schneller, das stimmt.
Das war aber am Anfang schneller.
Jetzt geht es wieder hoch.
Ja, ohne
mist leute sauce ford ist sauce ford sauce ford ist größte krebs seite mittlerweile erinnert ihr
euch noch ans aus ford da gab es früher mal ganz viele open source projekte das war eine richtig
gute seite genauso wie wie ist das andere code projekt oder sowas bevor es github gab die haben
komplett abgebaut.
Kannst du komplett vergessen, beides.
Ne, ne, das kam nicht aus dem Cache.
Der war ja viel weiter, als der da oben überhaupt war beim Download.
Das schwankt einfach.
rapid share
alter
das
war ein Titan
so
open media vault
jetzt war ich natürlich so blöd
und hab
machen wir mal aus
shutdown
war ich natürlich so blöd und hab kein CD-Laufwerk
in die Hardware reingehen
ach doch hier
use cd image file local okay ich habe die dinge an die falsche stelle kopiert wo müssen images
hin kopiert werden wieso images chat wo wo müssen isos hin kopiert werden bei bei box
template image aber wer to put isos proxmox directory template template iso
also nicht images sondern template iso oder iso wie cool leute das zu sagen so dann wollen wir
mal hier hardware cd storage local media world zack dachte das verdammte spiel escape verbot
menü bmw da sind für open media world install und erstes mal gucken also
bevor wir überhaupt was machen jetzt installieren wir bei open media world
erstmal disk benchmark und gucke mal wie schnell das ganze ist englisch europe
Germany. Musst du nicht dein Storage Volume für Isos konfigurieren? Habe ich schon.
Ich habe aktuell folgendes Setup. Werder installiert kann ich euch das zeigen. Guck mal.
Ich habe... warte mal.
Wir machen das anders.
Ich hab...
Ja.
Ich hab aktuell drei NVMe SSDs da drinnen.
Ich hab einmal ne 64GB.
Fragt nicht, warum es ne 64GB ist.
Minis Forum war der Meinung,
beste Größe, damit wird's ausgeliefert, okay?
Was war Open Media World nochmal?
Äh, ein Webinterface für Samba und Diskmanagement.
So mal grob zusammengefasst.
So, das ist die System-SSD.
Da ist Poxmox drauf.
Das ist übrigens die gleiche hier.
Dann habe ich noch hier einen RAID 1 drüber.
Ach, das ist übrigens meine...
Momente mal.
Ich habe da immer noch...
meine...
USV dranhängen und wir waren bei 14 Watt Idle. Moment, wenn ich die abmache, wo sind wir dann aktuell?
Ich kann übrigens gar nicht gucken.
Ich mach das mal ab.
Dann sollte zumindest das hier verschwinden an der Stelle.
Ja, jetzt sehe ich es nicht, weil der installiert ja im Hintergrund Debian.
Moin Abriss, Johnny.
So, und hier habe ich ein Rail 1 drüber.
Das heißt, aktuell ist es so eingerichtet, ISOs und Gedöns und Systemkram gehen hier auf diese 64GB SSD.
Ich baue da wahrscheinlich noch eine 1TB 970 EVO ein, die habe ich auch noch am Start, anstatt dem für das System.
Und das ist ein RAID 1 und da kommen alle VMs drauf.
Das ist aber ein Encrypted ZFS, also ich habe hier Zpool-Status.
Also ich habe quasi hier, List kann man da glaube ich machen, ne?
Genau, ich habe hier encrypted, also hier slash work, slash save ist encrypted.
Das muss ich immer anlocken, nachdem es gestartet ist.
Das heißt, alle meine VMs hier drauf, wo die VMs liegen, sind verschlüsselt.
CimaOS haben wir uns glaube ich das letzte Mal angeguckt, hat mir persönlich gar nicht gefallen.
Aus dem media world perfekt intern super
Ruth passwort 123456789
Moment moment chat ich bin auch kackt ich bin auch dumm und chat chat chat chat warte mal
Wurde jetzt schon netzwerk konflikt gemacht oder nicht
Ja konflikt netzwerk das will ich ja von hand konfigurieren
Your network is probably not using...
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich will das manuell config.
1.2.1.2.2.5.2 kriegt das.
Next.
Netmask.
Gateway.
50.
DNS.
Open Media Vault.
Internal.
Gut.
3789 massive passwort
Okay, da ist ja wieder die maus in der mitte was ist das jetzt schon wieder wo kommen die jetzt her
Jetzt weg
Könntest du auch über tpm ich kann es auch sein lassen
Ups.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Mach ich nicht.
Hast du eigentlich ein halbes Rechenzentrum, Keller?
Ne, ich hab gar nicht so viel.
Guck mal, du kannst...
Das ist nicht wirklich aktuell, das Video.
Das ist von 2021, also ist schon 5 Jahre alt.
Aber im Prinzip sieht das Rack immer noch so...
Naja, ne, da war ich gerade beim Umbauen.
So sieht das Rack nicht mehr aus.
Nehmen wir mal besser das ein bisschen...
Der Serverraum ist fertig.
Besseres Video.
Ja, sieht schon besser aus.
Hier.
Also das sieht im Prinzip immer noch so aus, ja.
Das ist ein kleines Rack.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr flaches und sehr kleines Rack.
Aber das ist kein Netzwerk-Rack, ja.
Also das ist ein ganz normales 19 Zoll Rack.
Aber hat glaube ich nur 24 HE oder sowas.
Und so sieht das im Prinzip eigentlich immer noch aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier irgendwo mal durchschwenke.
Hier schwenke ich durch, ja.
Ja, da war noch die alte 2HE-Kiste drin.
Da steht mittlerweile ein HP Microserver und da kommt jetzt auch das NAS hin.
Ja, gut, hier installieren.
Das ist immer noch eine USV, ja.
Aber ich habe nicht mehr die Cyberpower-USV, sondern eine billige APC-USV, die aber wenigstens nicht alles ausschaltet, wenn die Batterie Probleme hat.
Sechst.
da sind wir jetzt müsste ich eigentlich
geboten ist
52 als gut drauf kommt als gut überhaupt erlaubt ist meint
ihr gut über es das heißt überhaupt erlaubt ja glück gehabt
also hier sind wir bei unserem open media world ich war mal kurz und ab update und hau den mal
die neuesten packages drauf bevor wir da irgendwas anderes machen geht ja zackig ich sollte vielleicht
guck mal hier das wird da gemalt eingeschaltet um 18 uhr das machen wir mal kurz aus dass das
gefällt mir das gefällt mir also das ist eines der sachen die ich gut finde
oder wayland dass so sachen wie dark mode ordentlich funktionieren das war
oder x ziemlich krampf ich weiß dass das prinzipiell ging aber das ist schon
schöner dafür gibt es andere sachen nämlich
nerven
Wir können uns bei der Gelegenheit schon mal einloggen.
52.
Was war das?
Admin und dann Open Media Vault, glaube ich.
Safe.
Excellent.
Zack.
Dark Theme konnte man hier irgendwie einschalten.
Jawohl.
Top.
Das machen wir raus.
Dann sind wir auf unserem Open Media Vault.
system updates sind gleich durch da kann man mal gucken wie schnell die diske ist
wir inszenieren sie mal so ein paar standard tools also thema brauchen war
hart ob brauchen wir brauchen war
also es ist auch media volt eigentlich die bessere löhne vergleich zu tun hast
wenn man quasi einfach nur ein paar sammler shares haben will und vor allem
container auf eine andere maschine das ist ein bisschen geschmackssache ehrlich gesagt ja auch
media volt ist glaube ich deutlich flexibler was die storage sachen angeht bei tuners bist
glaube ich ich habe es ist schon ein bisschen her bist du glaube ich ziemlich fest gefahren
auf zfs weiß gar nicht ob man ob man schon als mit was andere mal zfs verwenden kann
also media volt ist wirklich ist schön schön simpel das was auch media wollen leider nicht
hat, meines Wissens nach, ist
Encryption Support
out of the box. Was für mich
Pflicht ist, weil ich will Festplatten einfach
in den Müll schmeißen können. Und die sollen
danach nicht mehr lesbar sein.
Also für mich ist
Encryption Support wichtig.
Aber nachdem die Sachen ja schon encrypted
sind, unterhalb von OutMedia Vault, ist das jetzt
nicht schlimm. Bei mir.
So, Apply.
Was genau habe ich gemacht, was ich applyen soll,
Chat?
CPU Power System
Okay.
Ich apply das einfach mal.
So, jetzt rebooten wir und dann schauen wir mal,
wie schnell das Ganze ist.
Pio.
Ups.
Oh, Chat.
Wie ging das nochmal?
Jetzt muss ich mir irgendwie ein Disk-Benchmark-Ding
wieder zusammenbasteln.
Hier, warte mal.
Pio sequential write
SSD-Benchmark.
ssd bench für grundlagen irgendwie sowas sei es ja num jobs ja genau irgendwie sowas in der
richtung um das besser vergleichen zu können machen wir jetzt einmal einen benchmark auf
dem host ok also gehen wir nach slash work und machen jetzt hier drin hier in der encrypted
disk man thema auf in der encrypted disk machen wir jetzt mal hier keckel bin das genau das brauche
also vielleicht habe ich das noch eine history nach schiff habe ich niemals vier ride name das
brauche auf jeden fall ein blog sei es klingt gut direct omannett file name ja keckel punkt bin
wieder keck punkt bin num jobs 1 engine da will ich nicht da will ich
sind kam glaube ich oder oder so etwas ist die standard engine 4
was gibt es dafür was ist die fault p
p-sync p-sync ist das die frau der platz
mal weg da mal schauen ob das jetzt
funktioniert runtime oder sowas genau
runtime 60 sekunden und jetzt muss ich
doch noch irgendwas anderes angeben dass
das funktioniert
was hat er denn für schmerzen geht das
ist nicht jobs die feind kann mir dieses zimmer merken wir fragen einfach die
eid über die weiß das schon max hast du gesehen wie die dubai
influenza rumheulen weil sie nicht von deutschland gerettet werde ich das geht
mir alles so was sonst wo vorbei ein base muss ich machen
Okay, Funst.
Was? Invalid Argument?
Ah, Size muss ich specifien.
10 Gig.
Size.
Okay, also.
Geschwindigkeit auf dem Host
sind, ja das geht jetzt ein bisschen runter.
Das ist aber normal.
Also Geschwindigkeit auf dem Host, auf das Raid 1 sind, ihr seht es hier übrigens, ja.
Also der haut ganz ordentlich zu, weil der muss sehr viel encrypten.
Das kann ich übrigens auch beweisen, dass das meiste an CPU-Leistung Kompression ist, nicht Encryption.
Was labere ich denn? Kompression ist.
Weil ich kann euch jetzt sagen, ähm, Perf, warte mal, wie hieß das Ding nochmal, Perf Linux oder sowas, Perf, Perf Linux, Perf oder, nicht iPerf.
perv wir haben das noch mal
linux perv hieß es genau install linux perv minus
So, jetzt führen wir hier oben nochmal aus.
Übrigens, wir machen ja immer 100 Gig, dass es nicht in irgendwelche Caches oder sonst wie reinpasst.
Also, 100 Sekunden I.O. Benchmark.
Und jetzt mache ich hier unten mal Perf Top.
Da sieht man jetzt nämlich, was für Kernelfunktionen aufgerufen werden.
Prozentual von der CPU-Zeit.
Und ihr seht hier, guckt mal.
ZFS LZ4 Compress ist auf 52%.
52 prozent das heißt 52 prozent des aktuellen cpu
aufkommens workload aufkommens ist lz 4
compression gefolgt von 5 prozent aes encryption
also das sieht deswegen sieht man auch dass das ding durchaus mit
1,4 1,2
Gig pro sekunde schreiben ziemlich gut beschäftigt ist
So, aber jetzt haben wir hier unseren Benchmark für den Host.
Den können wir jetzt mal in der VM ausführen.
Und mal gucken, wie schnell das Ganze da ist.
Das wird jetzt deutlich langsamer sein.
Das kann ich gleich dazu sagen, weil das hier ist jetzt ja noch eine emulierte SSD.
Also das wird jetzt richtig, richtig abfuck sein.
Oh, wobei.
Gar nicht so viel Unterschied.
Doch doch doch
Aber das ist auch nicht das was mich interessiert
So jetzt machen wir
Meine ssd in die vm rein
Also Worksafe
OMV
Ah, habe ich da schon mal was angelegt?
Das ist ja sehr nice
Ich lege mal was Neues an
Ich weiß nicht wofür es da ist
Keckel
Beste
Worksafe Keckel
So, dann gehen wir hier in Proxmox hin
Und sagen dem irgendwo unter
Directory Mappings
Hast du schon die französischen Sprachpakete?
Nee, schreib doch nochmal das Kommando, dass ich weiß, wie man die französischen Sprachpakete entfernt.
Ich glaube, das war rm-r-f-r, gell?
rm-f-r, richtig?
Minus fr.
Ja.
So und jetzt mappen wir die SSD in die VM.
Also nicht die SSD, das Laufwerk auf der SSD.
Hier, wird IOFS.
Mapping ID, Keckel.
Das kann man hier unter Advanced machen.
Cache.
Wir machen den Cache mal aus.
Direct IOS, okay.
Mal gucken, wie schnell das ist, ohne das zu verfälschen.
Jetzt schalte mal ein
Guck mal
Wie schnell das jetzt ist
Warte mal, was ist denn?
Leute, hier ist mein Clipboard
Ding, das muss ich auch nochmal
Bisschen besser
mir auf den Shortcut legen.
Okay, SSH.
So, mount-t
wird IOFS
mounten nach, ja,
keine Ahnung,
MNT.
Achso, Moment,
Peckle
hieß es, gell? Genau.
So, hier habe ich jetzt unter SlashMNT, seht ihr hier, guckt mal, da habe ich jetzt meine encryptete, komprimierte RAID 1 NVMe SSD liegen.
Und da machen wir jetzt mal einen Test, wie schnell der ist.
Ja, am Anfang flutscht das natürlich immer.
Gucken wir mal auf dem Haus, wie viel Auslastung wir haben.
Leute.
Ein Gigabyte pro Sekunde schreiben
macht halt schon ein bisschen Auslastung.
Aber die Performance ist
mehr oder weniger wie auf dem Host.
Gibt es eigentlich nichts zu meckern.
Ist vollkommen okay.
ist die verschlüsselung auf der nvm hardware offload die geht über die cpu die braucht gar
nicht so viel die verschlüsselung ist ich habe es doch gerade gezeigt kommt
mal die die verschlüsselung ist das nicht was so viel cpu last verursacht guck mal
das was viel cpu last verursacht ist die compression die lz 4 compression
Auf dem Synology oder QNAP-Nast, das explodiert quasi, das meldet.
Das kollabiert unter seiner eigenen Masse.
Die Compression ist das, was CPU-Last verursacht.
So, das ist doch relativ zackig, oder?
Kann man sich nicht beschweren.
Dann geben wir das doch mal frei.
Ach so, wenn ich den Kram hier maunte, kann ich da drüber was drauf schreiben ordentlich?
Warte mal, machen wir mal.
Komm, hier, der Klassiker.
CH-Mod 777.
Äh, Minusgross R.
Hast du einen Daumenwert, was du an Speicher sparst?
Speicher sparen? Für was Speicher sparen?
kann ich kann dir nicht ganz folgen mit lz 4 keine ahnung aber es ist gerade beim
dekomprimieren das ist halt so schnell gut dass du sagst lqs wir müssen noch
in openmedia wollte einen job einrichten dass das neu gestartet wird
der mount attribute command sagt so safe es lag ins jetzt gibt ein plugin dass man den
root folder scheren kann den brauchen war und jetzt gehen wir das ganze mal
über sammer frei und gucke mal wie schnell der es
wie du das ohne media volt machst dann machst du einen job at reboot geht
parken genauso
unter der haube wird das wahrscheinlich kontra
nicht automatischer reboot reboot
reboot anzunehmen kontakt schreiben so also weiter im text wie geben wir da
ordentlich was frei du hast recht man war aber ich habe noch nichts drauf wir
können noch gar nichts großartig gucken
wir können wir können gleich mal was drauf kopieren über das nass und mal
gucken wie viel das machen wir chat erinnert mich daran ich kopiere ich
kopiere meine linux vm da drauf hier auf dem desktop auf das nass wenn es dann
müssen wir gucken wie schnell es funktioniert und dann gucken wir mal wie
gut die compression ist das ist das war das ich nicht vergesse also work safe
compression value okay aktuell ist so gut wie nix compressed sagt das ist gut
das probieren wir mal aus was zum teufel ist mit out kommt rechen so das legen wir
uns am wasch her an services wir brauchen erst mal eine user sekunde user
Wir machen erstmal Samba an.
Samba, Settings,
Enabled.
Save.
Jaja, hier, passt.
Dann
legen wir einen User an.
Users.
Der heißt jetzt einfach Max.
Mit dem
Massive Passwort 123456.
Kommt keiner drauf.
Shell.
Äh.
Eigentlich braucht der gar kein Login.
Aber wie dem auch sei.
Ähm.
Groups.
Samba Share.
Save.
Ich glaube mehr braucht man nicht.
Okay.
Äh.
Und jetzt kann ich den Samba Share anlegen.
Ne jetzt muss ich den Share anlegen.
Und dann kann ich den Samba Share drauf machen.
Und dann mal gucken wie schnell der ist.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt.
Shared Folders.
Äh.
Ja.
Share.
Bester Name. Data. Data ist auch
immer gut. Das ist immer so schön nicht zu sagen.
Äh, MNT.
Legen wir doch mal
hier, guck mal, CD, MNT.
Haben wir doch hier mal irgendwas drunter. Nicht
Kekkelbin, sondern hier MKD.
So, MNT, Data.
Read, write,
everyone. Dann haben wir keine...
Okay.
Aber
ging anscheinend trotzdem.
Was auch immer OMV da jetzt für Schmerzen
hatte mit.
Shared Folders
und jetzt können wir einen Samba-Share anlegen.
Hast du auf der
NVMe auch die Duplication? Nein, nein, nein.
So, da habe ich nicht genug Rahmen für.
Data.
Browsable. Blablabla.
Ja, sollte passen.
Okay.
Chat, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie schnell das ist.
Ich muss erstmal kurz hier meine VMs aufmachen.
Stream-VM und hier brauchen wir ein schön großes...
Hier 200...
61 GB.
Das ist doch ein schönes Test-File.
So, und jetzt gehen wir mal...
192.168.2.52.
Max.123.556.
Aha, da sind wir.
Moin, Drewon
Okay
Chat, was meint ihr, wie schnell wird es sein?
Wie gesagt, wir haben es vorhin
Das sind die IPRF-Werte
Auf dem Haus, nicht auf der VM
Was meint ihr, wie viel kriegen wir durch?
So, über den Daumen gepeilt
200, 300, 400, 500, 600, 700, 800, 900
Gig, 1,1, 1,2 Gig
Okay, auch gleich, bam.
Oh.
Hups.
Ah, Classic Samba.
So, bam.
Einfach Zier motten.
Ah.
Ach, ich weiß, was es ist.
hatten wir schon mal. Jetzt habe ich vergessen.
Das habe ich vergessen.
Chat, wer weiß noch, was es ist?
Ich zeige es euch. Ich zeige es euch.
Warte mal. Mal gucken, ob ihr draufkommt.
Verdächtig, verdächtig, ne?
Gar nicht so viel.
Außer viel Interrupt vom Netzwerkkontroller.
Aber fällt euch vielleicht was auf?
Man sieht relativ wenig mit Encryption und sowas.
Multi-Samba?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das Problem ist,
wenn ich es euch zeige,
werdet ihr auch sagen, ach so.
Aber ich kann euch noch was anderes zeigen.
Vielleicht seht ihr es dann eher, woran es liegen könnte.
Das Problem hatte ich schon mal.
Deswegen weiß ich, was es ist.
Guck mal.
Das Samba-Ding hängt auf 100% Single-Core.
Komisch, oder? Verdächtig.
Eigentlich kann Samba multithreaded.
Ich zeige euch, was es ist.
Muss ich aber hier erstmal ausschalten.
Es ist die...
Singlecore, nein, das ist es nicht.
Take Viagra, die hat Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ich muss übrigens mal gucken,
ob es hier
noch mehr Subscribers
gab, die ich wieder komplett übersehen
habe.
Mal gucken.
Eine Umfrage,
welchen tag teilzeit ok kann man später noch machen oder nächsten stream wo jetzt
muss ich erst mal hier zu porto kommen
läuft das nass jetzt mit der anderen ja mit der an bordner zwei karte soll ich
kann euch zeigen wo es liegt es liegt hier an cpu
hier
ich muss
die Encryption
einschalten für die
VM, also dass die VM
die Hardware Encryption von der
CPU benutzen darf
das muss ich einschalten, sonst ist es lahm
weil das alles quasi in Software
erledigt werden muss
aber das haben wir
doch gemacht, nö
das hatten wir irgendwann mal gemacht
aber nicht für die vm die vm habe ich ja gerade von der fertigstunde installiert
ok let's go wie ist nicht verfügbar
da verarscht mich nicht warum sollte es nicht verfügbar sein
ok openmedia wollen was ist dein problem
Du hast Power Off gemacht.
Ja und?
Ist doch okay.
Ach, jetzt geht es wieder.
Der hat einfach gebraucht.
Für Paperless haben wir das gemacht.
Okay.
so okay chat nein ich will das nicht rufen aber es ist schnell es ist schnell okay
flutscht würde ich mal sagen oder
ein gig ungefähr
ist gut bin ich zufrieden
war hier hat top top
gut ist ganz gut ausgelastet das ding apple ist das gerade ist das den apple
den ich futter aber cpu auslastung ist jetzt nicht so krass das schon ganz gut
also das schafft ein bisschen was aber insgesamt hält sich den grenzen guck und
das bleibt auch relativ stabil relativ stable hammer schwankt ein bisschen
jetzt können wir noch mal die jetzt können wir noch mal hier diese
geschichte gucken die ihr sehen wolltet mit
auch guck mal wir sparen da schon ein bisschen was guck mal dass das geht echt gut hier lässt
sich gut das lässt sich richtig gut komprimieren wir haben 180 gig auf der platte just logical 284
also wir haben quasi hier 50 55 gig gespart das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht oder 50
ging und ich meine, da ist ja kaum was drauf.
Also
LZ4-Encryption, so bei normalem
Kram, lohnt sich schon.
Letztendlich ist das ja auch nur eine Linux-Distribution,
die hier drin ist.
Was wird gemacht? Ich gucke, wie schnell
ich Samba auf meinem Nass zum Laufen kriege.
Aktuell ist es noch nicht so
wirklich das High-Performance-Setup,
weil es noch selbst in der VM läuft.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn das schon nicht das
performance setup ist was meint ihr dann wie schnell das in einem lxc container flutschen wird
das ist vollkommen fein leute guck mal hier 1,1 1,01 so ungefähr ein gigabyte pro sekunde so im
durchschnitt das ist super da kann man sich überhaupt nicht beschwert und ihr seht auch
mal das ist ziemlich konstant ja das ist ziemlich konstant also das nicht irgendwie so sägezahn
Muster oder sowas. Das ist ziemlich konstant.
Da kannst du dich eigentlich drauf verlassen.
Das sind auch nicht irgendwelche
Caches, die jetzt einfach mal schnell
schnell sind und dann lahm.
Das ist echt ein Übel.
Also kannst du nichts sagen.
Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch
ungefähr an die Performance, als die Netzwerkkarte
nicht richtig mitgemacht hat.
Das konntest du komplett knicken.
Ja, schön schnell.
So, ähm, ich werde das jetzt mal fertig kopieren lassen.
Und dann gucken wir nochmal, wie viel wir gespart haben.
Also wir haben jetzt 261 Gigabyte kopiert.
In, sieht man das irgendwie, wie lange es gebraucht hat?
Ne, diese Anzeige gibt es in Windows natürlich nicht.
Es gibt nur Time Remaining.
Time insgesamt juckt nicht.
warum gibt es kein time elapsed oder sowas hat microsoft nicht genug vibecoded
gibt's nicht
was wäre denn wenn du NVMe over TCP benutzt das wäre wahrscheinlich schneller
ja ja ja das ziemlich sicher wäre schneller aber da hast natürlich die
ganzen zwischenschichten nicht die auch was machen dann hast du quasi kannst du
beispiel nicht scheren den den folder kannst du nicht diese magic machen mit
white cash was ich machen will wie findest du das neue startmenü habe ich
das schon chat ist das neue startmenü ist das hier unten das neue
Ähm
Ähm, Chat
Wie komme ich denn jetzt auf meine Programme?
Hier, show all
Ne, das sind Recommended Files
Wie kriege ich denn jetzt eine Liste von allen meinen Programmen?
List
Achso
Naja
Das haben die bestimmt
Vibe-Coded
Zoom VDI-Meeting-Plugin
Warum habe ich denn sowas da drauf?
Oh
Ich weiß, man kann tippen, aber
Das ist schon echt nicht so dolle
Aber ich erwarte da von Windows auch nichts mehr, ehrlich gesagt.
Beziehungsweise von Windows ist ja falsch.
Von den Microsoft-Vibe-Codern erwarte ich da eigentlich auch nichts mehr.
Übrigens, aus meiner Sicht ist der einzige oder der Haupt...
Ne, der einzige, der einzige ist übertrieben.
Der Hauptgrund, warum das Startmenü...
Erstmal, alles klar.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass das Startmenü eine JavaScript-Anwendung ist?
Eine React-Anwendung?
da fragt man sich so was
React, JavaScript, das Startmenü
warum
aber wisst ihr das
das Startmenü ist eine React Anwendung
das ist quasi ein Browser was ihr hier seht
das ist ein Browser
wobei ich weiß es nicht ob es React
oder React Native ist, wenn es React Native ist
ist es nicht unbedingt ein Browser
und meiner Meinung nach
eines der
ein guter, also
eines der Gründe, warum Microsoft das
gemacht hat, ist, weil
ChatGPT und AI-Tools
deutlich besser darin,
JavaScript zu
auszuspucken,
JavaScript zu generieren,
als irgendwelchen
Low-Level-Windows-Code mit
Windows-C-AP
aufrufen.
Deswegen ist das in
JavaScript, ist meine Theorie.
das Microsoft, Microsoft-Slob richtig sloppen kann.
Ist das.
Und ja, der Chef von Microsoft mag das nicht, wenn man es Microsoft-Slob nennt.
Aber da hat er sich selbst reingeritten.
Das ist nicht mein Problem.
Die können zwar Discord-Server schließen, aber Chat, unseren Chat können sie nicht schließen.
hast du mal wieder meeting mit micro schloss schon lange nicht mehr
wir waren letztens bei google in frankfurt den neuen büros aber ratet mal
wer sich davor gedrückt hat auf solche social events ratet mal wenn ich
hingegangen ist
ich ja ich bin nicht hingegangen hat mich auch überhaupt nicht gejuckt wie es
bei google ausschaut
da arbeiten die high performer da gehöre ich nicht hin leute
habt ihr das auch auf der arbeit us firmen zumal du weißt du wie das auch
vorhaben us firmen zu ersetzen
Ja es gibt bei uns auf der arbeit ein
Test ein testaufbau ob sich das ob sich das eignet
mit der lidl cloud
aber das ist wohl nicht so gut weggekommen bis jetzt
Was ich so gehört habe
guck mal hier leute
compression
wir haben 395 gigabyte
kompresst auf 274 wir haben 120 gig gespart dadurch dass das kommt das lz 4 compression
an ist jetzt jetzt skaliert das mal hoch auf eine 26 terabyte festplatte
F-Programmer, wirklich?
Den habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen,
den Yonder-Boy.
Aber überlegt euch mal,
wenn man sich das alles so gut komprimieren lässt,
wie Linux, wie eine Linux-Image,
läuft die Lidl-Cloud nicht auf der Google-Cloud?
Nee.
Das lohnt sich richtig, ja.
So, löschen wir das mal wieder,
dass ich gleich neu kopieren kann.
War das Pfeil der VM wirklich so groß?
261 Gig, ja.
So, Leute, also.
Das ist doch relativ nice
jetzt gewesen. Dann gucken wir mal,
wenn wir jetzt mal theoretisch,
also was ich, was ich mir ja vor,
was mir ja vorschwebt ist,
HDD
plus MergerFS
SSD, Write Cache.
Ich kann das jetzt mit der HDD nicht ausprobieren,
weil ich keine HDD
gerade hierfür habe.
Da müsste ich erstmal ausbauen.
Aber wir können das mit
MergerFS probieren schon mal,
wie schnell das Ganze dann ist.
Also die Idee dahinter
ist folgendes.
Ich habe einen RAID, sag mal ich habe einen RAID 5.
Okay.
RAID 5 ist MNT
Slow Disk.
Sagen wir jetzt mal.
Ja.
Und ich hab...
Ich hab nen NVMe-Rate 1.
Das ist MNT Fast Disk.
Und ich will jetzt...
Neue Dateien, die über das NAS geschrieben werden.
Haben wir Stacking?
Haben wir Leute?
haben wir leute von der schwarz gruppe
ich muss mal kurz mein toastbrot futter fertig von der switch hat
wenn du im kaufwerk wenn du im kaufland neue netzwerksdaten angeschlossen hast
vielleicht.
Gehören die da auch dazu?
gar nicht weil mir die switches fehlen für mehr als zehn gig und ich den anwendungszweck gerade
auch bei mir nicht sehr so was jetzt machen will ist ich will das neue dateien immer hier drauf
landen und die werden dann nächtlich quasi weg gemovt hierhin und das will ich mit mercer fs
machen habe ich schon mal ausprobiert aber nur ganz kurz und wenig sagen die pfeife ja da gibt
angeblich ein Plugin, habe ich gelesen
für MergerFS.
Gucken wir mal. Plugins.
Könntest du auch...
Ah, Moment.
Könntest du auch sogar eine RAM-Disk als Fastest
nehmen, oder? Ja.
Mein Problem ist nur...
Also, mehrere Probleme.
Die VM hat nur 8 GB RAM.
Mein Host hat nur 32 GB RAM.
Und die ist
ein paar sekunden voll geschrieben die randes und ich habe keinen ram mehr für die vms und alles
ist
Okay, Merger.
Gibt es nicht. Moment.
OMV Merger FS. Was ist das hier?
Gab es da ein Plugin für?
Ach, das war ein Zusatz-
ein Zusatz-Repo oder was?
Oh, die Seite sieht ja hochprofessionell aus.
Das ist ein Doku-Wiki oder sowas.
Oh, mein Auge, Alter.
Uiuiui.
Close.
Fast erblindet.
Wie installiert man dieses Zusatz-Dings-Repo?
Das habe ich irgendwann schon mal gemacht.
Wie funzt das hier?
Äh.
How to install OMV8
Beta Release
OMV8 ist ein Rolling Release
Ach
Interessant
Cool. Und was gibt es Neues?
In OMV 8?
Okay.
Ja, ja.
OMV Extras muss drauf.
Ich suche nur gerade,
wie man OMV Extras installiert.
Hier.
Hä?
Gibt's da nicht irgendwie einen?
Ach hier, hier, guck mal.
Das da, okay.
Komische WGAT-Kommandos runnen.
Okay.
wir kommen einfach random sachen internet direkt als root wegen nach
best pein was kann schon verkehrt kann schon schief gehen was kann da schon
verkehrt sein dran
yolo so und jetzt aber jetzt plugins wo es ein merger fs gibt merker fs da ist
ist 8 ok macht es sinn dass das 8.0 heißt
was habe ich denn für ein open media wollte überhaupt
13, das ist doch Trixi.
Habe ich denn schon OMV8?
Woher weiß ich denn, was für eine Open-Media-Wolf-Version ich habe?
Dashboard, System?
System?
Gibt es sowas wie About oder sowas?
Leute, woher weiß ich, welche Open-Media-About?
ob media volt ja und fernseher bau page diagnostik system information 8.8 habe
ich schon dann ist ja easy habe ich ja schon
ok also dann merger fs da müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen das ganze
angucken also nehmen jetzt einfach mal merger systems nie pass will ich haben also wir nehmen
jetzt einfach mal nur mnt data sonst nix das ist jetzt unter der haube ist es die ssd aber
Wurscht, ich will es einfach mit dem Zwischenschritt ausprobieren.
MNT-Data.
First Found.
Gibt ja nur einen.
Minimum Free Space.
Gigabytes.
Defaults Cache.
So, was ich jetzt gelesen habe, mit der neuen Merger-FS-Version.
Gibt es sowas, das heißt...
Irgendwas mit Path, Path Through oder sowas.
Und das soll angeblich noch schneller sein dann.
Wie aktiviere ich das Ganze denn?
Cache Files must be full or autofull.
Was auch immer das bedeutet.
Okay.
Weiß nicht, wie man das benutzt.
Path
through.
It should be path through
RW.
Okay.
das da will ich haben. Ich klau das einfach von dem
Dude hier.
Also.
Die Falls Path
to Cache Files
Auto Full. Ohne, dass ich
jetzt weiß, was es bedeutet. Einfach
mal abschicken.
Okay.
Einfach ein Merger-FS
und wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Jetzt kann ich euch einfach sagen,
Shared Folder-Klein.
ok fonds fonds fonds hier shared folder merger ich nenne das jetzt auch so dass ich wieder finde
relative path ok read write everyone save srv merger fs merger bester filename überhaupt da
Da weiß man ja sofort, was gemeint ist, oder?
SAV, Merger, FS, Merger, Merger.
Hast du mal Anred?
Ja.
Ich wechsel nicht zu Open Media Vault.
Ich wechsel zu Proxmox und darauf vielleicht, vielleicht eine Open Media Vault VM.
Mal gucken.
So, und jetzt sagen wir SambaShares.
Add.
Merger.
Bam.
So, und jetzt sollte das über MergerFS gehen.
Das hat jetzt keinen wirklichen Mehrwert aktuell, ja, weil da noch keine Festplatte dabei ist.
Aber von der Idee her ist das mit MergerFS, so wie ich es eben auf die Konsole gemalt habe.
Also sprich, ich hänge dann hier den Pfad zu meiner HDD drunter und dann macht er dadurch, dass hier First Found steht,
packt der neue Files immer auf die SSD
und dann kann ich die nachts von der SSD wegmoven.
Soweit die Idee.
Hier, Merger.
Ne, Moment mal, wo muss ich denn hier?
Merger, da muss ich hin.
Okay, mal gucken, wie schnell es jetzt ist.
Geht immer noch voll klar.
Es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
So 50, 60 MB langsamer.
Aber vollkommen fein immer noch die Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit.
Oh, es wird schneller. Es gibt Gas, Leute.
Mal gucken, wie jetzt die CPU-Auslastung ist hier.
Juckt die nicht, juckt die nicht.
Und hier auf dem Host.
Ja, aber das geht ja noch, klar.
Das ist jetzt ja nicht, dass man sagen müsste,
hier das ist kurz vorm kurz vor der kernschmelze oder so irgendwas hängt
hier auf hängt hier ziemlich ausgelastet auf einer cpu was dafür eine cpu drunter
ein reisen 7 255 das ist einer mit acht kern und 16 fritz also ziemlich ziemlich
wumms für eine mass und also gute kombination weil preis leistungsmäßig gut und eitel stromverbrauch
ziemlich niedrig also eigentlich top cpu dafür gucke mal leute es ist kaum langsam es ist ein
bisschen langsamer ja bisschen aber im großen und ganzen merkst du eigentlich keinen unterschied
jetzt es ist so 20 20 20 30 mb vielleicht langsamer aber das macht bei den geschwindigkeiten
jetzt nicht viel aus und es heißt im endeffekt ich hab jetzt jetzt ja schon
mercer fs dazwischen das ist nice kommt der f5 mit einer der n5 mit einem us
vorhin zählt ja aber das habe ich sofort runter geschmissen
instant kick bahn gg
Ja, aber
sag doch mal, Chad, die Geschwindigkeit
geht doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Wollen wir es mal mit einer Magnetfestplatte
ausprobieren? Ich habe hier noch so eine
richtig billige
Magnetfestplatte.
Können wir mal da rein machen. Wartet mal.
Ich muss noch kurz was futtern.
Kann ich
aus dem anderen Nas raus machen?
Was für ein Messer?
Also ich habe jetzt Proxmox drauf.
Proxmox
mit einer Open Media Wall vor allem.
Wartet mal. Ich gucke mal, wo ich
diese Billigplatte
habe.
Hier.
Glaube ich. Oder?
Ja.
Hier ist sie.
Oh, die ist da fest. Ist die da festgeschraubt?
Oder wie ist das? Moment mal.
Wie ging dieser komische Wechselrahmen hier nochmal?
Ah, ne, einfach drücken, oder?
Ah ja, okay, okay.
Jetzt können wir gleich mal gucken, ob...
...ob das Ding Hotswap-fähig ist.
Oder ob es nur Hotswap-fähig...
Also es ist auf jeden Fall Hotswap-fähig, habe ich schon im Internet gelesen.
Oder ob es nur Hotswap-fähig ist...
wenn der Slot beim Booten
schon besetzt war.
Von der Platte. Also,
die Mask.
Ich schiebe jetzt mal kurz.
Warte mal, ich muss erstmal hier einmal so
einen Wechselrahmen rausholen und mal gucken,
wie man das reinkriegt.
Äh.
Hä?
Moment, wie ist denn die Taktik
hier?
Chat, ich verstehe es nicht so genau, wie das funktioniert mit der Platte.
So.
Ich glaube, ich mache gerade was kaputt.
Ist nicht so geil.
Oh.
Ah.
Man kann das abmachen an der Seite.
Ich kapiere das nicht.
Wie zum Teufel funktioniert dieses Wechsel-Disk-Platten-Teil?
Okay, jetzt ist es drin.
Jetzt ist es drin.
Jetzt muss ich das wieder draufsetzen, oder wie?
Aber ich kann es euch heute leider nicht zeigen,
weil ich die Kamera nicht anhabe.
Aber das System ist nicht so geil.
Muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Mit der Platte.
Da habe ich schon deutlich
angenehmeres
gesehen.
Okay.
So.
Ich habe die Platte dran.
Jetzt mache ich die Platte mal rein in das Nass.
Das Näs.
So, geht's an.
Ich glaube, es dreht hoch.
Was macht der Tisch? Ich habe immer noch nicht genug aufgeräumt.
Ah.
Guck mal da.
Was haben wir denn da? SDA ist am Start.
Das ist übrigens die letzte, räudigste Festplatte.
Ich kann es euch zeigen.
Def
Def SCA
Guck mal
Das ist eine 2 Terabyte
WD20
Also das ist wirklich ganz großer Crap
Aus der heutigen Sicht
Hier guck mal
Eine 2 Terabyte WD Cream
Die hat was weiß ich 50 MB die Sekunde oder so
Ja standardmäßig kommt das Ding mit Minis Cloud OS
Leute das wollt ihr nicht benutzen
Das wollt ihr nicht benutzen
Das ist Müll
Also dafür würde ich mir das nicht kaufen
Okay
Dann
Lass mal kurz in mich gehen
Was muss ich jetzt überhaupt machen
Ich muss ZFS drauf installieren
Also
Z
Zpool
Wobei ging das nicht
Über Proxmox
Irgendwie mit ZFS sogar
kann ich nicht sagen dass da discs
da ist schon ein cds drauf das machen wir noch mal neu würde ich sagen bei
white white disc
ok und wie mache ich jetzt den ZFS da drauf
ach hier unten drunter
create ZFS
HDD
ok da kommt es rein
A-Shift 12
was benutzt man für einen A-Shift
ZFS A-Shift
A-Shift hört sich auf Deutsch irgendwie ziemlich unanständig an
für HDDs
Okay, komm, ich lasse jetzt einfach mal.
Compression on.
Selbstverständlich, Compression on.
Single Disc.
Create.
Schau mal, ein Apfel runtergeschmissen.
So.
Okay, jetzt haben wir die Kiste hier.
Äh, Zpool
Status
Äh
List
Da ist es.
Slash HDD
So, äh, ZFS
Encrypt, oh, das kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
ZFS
Hm
Create, Encrypt
Ich kann
es mir nicht merken.
Und jetzt, Zeravesc, create, minus O, Encryption, on.
Das da.
Zeravesc, create, Encryption, on.
HDD, Slash, auch Save.
Das heißt immer Save, weil verschlüsselt.
Ach so, Passphrase.
Passphrase.
Analyse Oracle.
Ah, ja, ja.
Das ist natürlich.
Passphrase.
Moment.
Die AI.
Sag den.
Key Format Passphrase.
Genau.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Massive.
Da kommt nie jemand drauf.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir hier unsere SSD.
Da haben wir hier auch nochmal den Ordner Kekkel drin.
Den brauchen wir für die VM.
So.
Jetzt gehen wir auf unseren Proxmox.
Sagen wir nochmal, wir wollen Ordner-Mapping
machen. Und zwar
jetzt HDD-Safe-Keckel.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht mehr Keckel nennen, sondern
HDD-Keckel. Dass man auch
Bescheid weiß.
Und jetzt schalten
wir die OMV
Kiste
aus. Mappen
uns per Wirt.io
FS
HDD-Keckel.
Lassen hier mal alles
auf No Cache.
Und sagen jetzt hier,
add.
Okay.
So, Start.
Jetzt testen wir mal, wie schnell
die Festplatte ist.
Die dürfte abfuck langsam sein.
Äh.
Moment, wie viele?
Will ich mich veräppeln?
wie viele wie viele einträge speicher denn bitteschön der der clipboard manager
hier das speicher zehn stück oder was ist du gesagt ist alle history sei es
wie mehr geht nicht doch was ist das maximum was geht
Was ist denn das Maximum, was hier geht?
Okay, 2048.
Apply.
Also schauen wir mal, wie schnell das Ganze ist auf der HDD.
HDD, ja, HDD, Save, Cackle.
Wir machen den gleichen Test wie auf der SSD, wobei das mit der Block Size nicht so nice ist.
Naja, na gut, noch ist der Cache nicht voll.
Wenn der Cache voll ist, dann geht es langsamer.
Aber geht doch noch, oder?
jedoch klar 100 100 mb die sekunde 120 mb die sekunden vollkommen fein
ok dann gehen wir und unsere vm so dann jetzt jetzt mk dir keine ahnung könnt ihr mnt 2
das wird richtig aber nicht so mount hdd keckel nach mnt 2 soll erst mal alle 777 moden um zu
gucken, ob es funktioniert. So, und der
MNT2 haben wir jetzt
Ekel binnenlegen. Das schmeißen wir weg.
Okay.
Gut. Dann schauen wir mal,
ob das jetzt funktioniert, was ich mir gedacht habe.
Wir stellen jetzt
in Open Media Vault folgendes
ein bei MergerFS.
Moment. Vorher brauchen wir noch einmal,
dass er das auch immer mountet.
Mount.
So, dann müssen wir nämlich noch ein
Schedule Task machen, dass der
beim Reboot
diesen anderen Krempel auch
mounted. So.
Jetzt MergerFS.
Erstmal
speichern. Yes.
MNT Data.
Wir wollen MNT2
Data haben.
Okay.
MNT2
Data. So. Das haben wir hier die
schnelle Disk und hier die langsame Disk.
Speichern.
unschlüssig, ob das reicht.
Wir können aber mal testen, ob es funktioniert.
Weil, ich gehe jetzt mal hier hin,
auf die Festplatte.
Hier machen wir Touch, Touch, HDD.
Und dann gehen wir hier nach MNT,
das ist die SSD, Touch, SSD.
So, wenn MergerFS jetzt richtig funktioniert,
Moment mal.
Wenn MergerFS jetzt richtig funktioniert,
und gibt es da noch mal mercer ich bin ich natürlich wenn wir jetzt richtig funktioniert
dann habe ich hdd und ssd file im gleichen ordner was macht wird die ufs das mounted
ein virtuels drive damit kannst du quasi ordner vom haus durchreichen so gucken wir jetzt mal
hier hin sagt merger ist leer es funktioniert schon mal nicht so weil es ja nicht im sammer
verzeichnis ist ich kann moment moment moment event 2 wir haben ja hier welches welches
verzeichnis haben hier gemeldet shared
folder das ist ja das ist ja ein high
IQ Shit das muss ich noch mal anders
machen
ich bin ich bin ich auch nicht zurecht
ok wir brauchen hier data
Warte, ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Meine Ordner sind zu gut benannt.
Okay, Data Merger.
Also das muss hier rein.
SSD.
Okay, gut.
So, MNT2.
Data.
MKD Merger.
MV
Okay
So, komm, wir CR-Modden
jetzt nochmal alles
Also irgendwie ist da nichts
drinne
Wie kann das sein?
Data, Merger, SSD
Und in Merger ist nichts drinne
Warum nicht?
Okay, ich kopiere da jetzt mal irgendwas rein
Ja, so hier, bam
Ein Gig, kopieren wir da mal rein
Da ist es.
So, wo liegt es jetzt?
Wo liegt es jetzt?
MNT?
Data?
Da ist es doch.
Äh, Chat?
Warum wird das angezeigt,
aber SSD nicht?
Kann es sein, dass ich das...
Ach so, okay.
Ich hätte einfach mal F5 drücken müssen.
Wuppl ausgrippt.
Ja.
Wir brauchen Wubblos-Skript und wir brauchen Wubblos-Kompress.
Dann haben wir alles.
Okay, Leute, so ganz funzt das nicht, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ich glaube, wir müssen die Kiste nochmal neu starten, weil MerchFS irgendwie das nicht gecheckt hat,
dass ich die Platte noch zusätzlich da reingehängt habe.
Aber, aber, aber geben tut's, aber geben.
Okay, geben tut's das.
Okay, reboot.
Excellent.
wir haben einen blick weiter oben auf den link mit dem band nicht übrigens geiles feature ach
den hier meinst du wenn du den jetzt quotiert diesen post vom series max dann kann ich hier
den chat verlauf gucken in chatarino da finde ich das dann schneller aber dann wenn das jetzt
drei oben drüber passt schon also was ist denn das company behind band genau
was was zum teufel geht ab wie kann ich telefonisch einflug bei condor buchen
Was?
Dreht Open Claw da gerade durch bei dem?
Was ist das für ein Dude?
Ja.
Open the first issue.
Oh Mann! Die armen Maintainers ey! Die armen Maintainers man!
Gut dass der Fiat Champ noch keinen AI-Slob kriegt. Wobei das macht nichts.
Den Merge ich genauso wenig wie nicht AI-Slob. Müsste ich erst mal wieder was machen.
Okay, jetzt lasst mal gucken.
Checkt der das denn?
Ah, guck mal, es funktioniert.
Ich sehe im gleichen Ordner die Files von der HDD und von der SSD.
So, und wenn ich das jetzt richtig konfiguriert habe,
dann gehen neue Files...
Okay, es ist ein bisschen langsamer.
Nee, nee, geht schon.
Guck mal, das funktioniert.
Neue Files gehen jetzt auf die SSD.
und dann werde ich einmal nachts die files von der ssd auf die disk rufen versteht man was ich
vorhaben eigentlich ist das ziemlich nice das ist quasi so ein ssd ride cash weil für den inhalt
hier in diesem ordner ist es komplett egal wo das liegt es sieht immer gleich aus also der
sammer client erkennt überhaupt nicht ob das auf der ssd oder auf der hdd liegt
guck ich zeig's ich zeig's euch mal also ich kopiere jetzt mal ich kopiere jetzt
mal hier diesen gram hier wieder dahin okay quasi so was wie android auch macht
ja android macht ja was sehr ähnliches genau so also ich habe jetzt ich habe
jetzt hier dieses virtual disk image liegen das virtual disk image liegt wenn
man sich sagen, SRV, Merger, Merger,
geile Ordnernamen.
Das ist das, was ich quasi sehe auf
meinem Samba-Share.
Simple Form von Storage-Tiering.
Genau. So, unter der Haube
sieht das so aus. MNT,
auf der SSD liegt das hier Kram,
liegt das hier drauf, guck,
auf der HDD liegt nix.
Jetzt kann ich aber sagen,
move mir
MNT
Data Merger
Stream nach
MNT2
Merger, dahin.
So, jetzt wird das gemovt.
Das ist lahm.
Jetzt wird das gemovt von der SSD auf die HDD.
Guckt, jetzt liegt es hier.
Aber
hier in der Ansicht
im Frontend quasi,
macht es keinen Unterschied. Und man sieht
auch, dass es auf der HDD ist, denke
ich mal. Wobei, das ist zu klein.
Das ist zu klein. Das kommt alles
noch aus dem Cache.
Aber man sieht's also die Daten liegen allein schon das das kopieren funktioniert hat. Warum kein B-Cache?
Weil ich in dem Open Media Vault keinen Zugriff direkt auf die Devices habe. Die Devices sind in meinem Host und die brauche ich auch für meine Proxmox VMs.
Eigentlich ist das ein ziemlich nice Setup, das gefällt mir gut.
Excellent oder?
X, X, X, X, X, X.
Guck mal, wie
flott der 25 Giga
drauf schreibt hier.
Das saugt das einfach rüber übers Netzwerk.
Okay, der ist ein bisschen
langsamer jetzt.
Immer noch zackig.
Jetzt saugt
richtig.
Saugungsstelz.
Nächsten Stream, by the way, ich seh nämlich
gerade, ich hab nicht mehr viel Zeit.
Nächsten Stream, probieren wir das Ganze in dem
LXT-Container aus und gucken, wie viel schneller
wir es noch hinkriegen.
Was passiert,
wenn du was kopierst, was zu groß
für die SSD ist?
Das kann man bei
MergerFS einstellen.
Man kann sagen, MergerFS sagt dann
wie gehabt
No Space Left on Device.
Was natürlich schwierig ist.
Ich meine, ich habe einen Terabyte.
Da müsste ich eine Datei kopieren, die größer als
ein Terabyte ist.
Oder MergerFS
kann das unter der Haube auch irgendwie umlinken.
Dass es dann kurz freest, aber alles auf die HDD verschiebt und dann weiter kopiert.
Das geht auch irgendwie.
Habe ich aber nicht eingeschaltet.
Was wir machen, wir gucken, wie schnell mein Nass ist.
Es geht nicht mehr so lange, noch 10 Minuten vielleicht.
So, jetzt haben wir den Kram hier wieder auf der SSD liegen.
gucken wir mal chat wir machen jetzt die
machen jetzt die umständlichste art und weise eine datei zu kopieren die ihr gesehen habt
wir kämpfen das jetzt nach pv und dann schreiben wir die datei wieder
dahin weil ich will ich will wissen wie schnell er jetzt kopiert auf die auf die festplatte
nein nein das stimmt nicht das ist gelogen okay jetzt wird es lang jetzt wird es langsam
realistischer aber immer noch zu schnell dass ich weiß warum das so schnell ist weil zfs wahrscheinlich
was im Rahmen cached.
Es ist immer noch
deutlich zu schnell.
Aber ZFS
wird irgendwas cachen.
Ja, guck, jetzt geht's runter.
also wir haben 25 gig das braucht noch kurz
was ist denn das besondere an zfs dass du sehr viele features hast wie zum beispiel
eingebaute verschlüsselung eingebaute on the fly transparente compression dass
du automatisch checksum checking hast von den einzelnen sektoren das sind
nichts kaputt gehen kann also relativ easy backups machen kannst
über das netzwerk von zfz zu zfz zfz kann total viel das schnellste ist es
nicht das stellt also wer absolute high end performance so schnell wie sie
möglich ist haben will der ist vielleicht bei cfs falsch aber es ist
auf jeden fall schnell genug so schau mal da es sieht immer noch so aus wie
vorher obwohl die datei jetzt auf der auf der festplatte ist jetzt lesen wir
mal die datei wieder von der festplatte da ist jetzt halt so viel
das geht etwas zeug das meiste ist halt noch im cash drin
das steckt noch im cash weil ich das gerade kopiert habe das ist
vielleicht kein allzu kein allzu guter test jetzt
kein allzu guter test wir machen einen anderen test
Wir machen einfach einen anderen Test
Wir machen einen anderen Test
Ganz einfach
Cat dev u random
Gepiped nach pv
Gepiped nach mnt2
lup.bin
So
Da schreiben wir jetzt irgendwie so
weiß ich nicht, 15 Gig oder so
rein und das kopieren wir dann.
Und es sind auch Random-Daten, da ist
eh schwierig, irgendwas zu optimieren.
Da sieht man gleich schon, wird schon ein bisschen langsamer.
Ich finde diese Mario Kart Musik super entspannend.
Die ist happy und irgendwie verbreitet es gute Stimmung.
Aber die ist nicht so nervig.
Ich habe das echt gerne im Hintergrund.
Habe ich teilweise sogar auf der Arbeit im Hintergrund an.
So was.
Chat.
Nächster Stream.
Also, das machen wir jetzt noch fertig, ne?
Nächster Stream probieren wir das Ganze mal mit dem LXC-Container aus.
Falls ich es vergesse, erinnert mich dran.
Und nächste Woche
wird
Seagate-Festplatte
geschuckt.
Stimmt, Stellenanzeigen, ja.
Ab wann nächstes YouTube-Update?
Physieausbildung, ja, ich hoffe
Hast du, Moment, ich hab's jetzt nicht richtig gelesen
Hast du die jetzt, die Prüfung
oder hast du die jetzt geschafft?
Beende diesen Sommer
meine Physieausbildung, muss mich
jobtechnisch umschalten, übernehme ich dich nicht
oder willst du nicht da bleiben, weil Kackladen
Ein Jobupdate von dir wäre mein Traum
Oh, da gibt's, da gibt's nicht so viel
Spannendes, aber Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich kann's übersehen, danke Leute
Übrigens danke für alle Subs, die es
Vielleicht gegeben hat, die ich nicht gesehen habe.
Massive Subscriber.
Also ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, wann es ein YouTube-Update gibt.
Arctics, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich war kurz davor, die letzten paar Wochen immer mal ein Video aufzunehmen, aber...
Ich bin einfach kopfmäßig noch nicht frei dafür.
Der Meeps, Pog, Subscriptions, danke Leute.
Wenn ihr nächsten Stream auch dabei sein wollt, jetzt das Follow nicht vergessen.
So, jetzt haben wir jetzt WanschGig.
Sync.
Ey, das auf Flush.
Flush ist auf die Platte.
Ich hab nicht mehr viel Zeit.
In acht Minuten, Chat, muss ich rüber.
First Level Support wird outgesourced, aber find schon was.
Bin sehr selten auf Twitch, aber wenn sowas kommt, wäre Hammer.
Ich kann es dir nicht versprechen.
Kanisterköppel, dankeschön für den Sub.
Macht dir nichts raus.
First Level suckt eh komplett.
Gut, es gibt Leute, die mögen das.
Aber ich kenne keinen,
der es mag.
Guck mal mal, wie schnell das jetzt ist von der Platte.
Okay, das ist
genau das, was ich erwartet habe.
Guck, er liest mit
ja, whatever
120 irgendwas
Das kommt jetzt eindeutig von der Platte.
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch,
dass das alles mit diesem
Fake-Tiered Storage
funktioniert. Ne, das kann ich euch nicht zeigen,
weil ich den Kram ja nicht auf der SSD hab.
Aber ich sag mal so,
ich kann's auf die SSD kopieren.
MNT2
Intermerger-Blob.bin
Jetzt moven wir das mal jetzt.
sehe ich natürlich nicht, wie weit wir sind.
Sehr schlau, Max.
Mach es wie FireShip und lass
deine Videos per KI erstellen.
Bei dem bin ich mir echt nicht sicher, ob er seine Stimme
komplett digitalisiert hat und das gar nicht
mehr selbst spricht.
Dann habe ich Pech, wenn das so ist.
Aber ich habe mir ein Shocking-Video
angeguckt auf YouTube und
da waren SATA-Ports dran.
Sorry, falls dies heute schon öfters gefragt wurde.
Ach Quatsch, ich kann auch Sachen ein paar Mal sagen.
Das ist normal bei Streams, dass nicht einer...
Die wenigsten Leute sind von Sekunde aus, außer der RF-Programmer und der Feudia und so,
die sind seit Sekunde 1 dabei und sind bis zum Ende des Streams dabei.
Das ist bei den wenigsten der Fall.
Kannst ruhig fragen.
Also, sorry, falls dies heute schon öfters gefragt wurde.
Aber kannst du bitte nochmal dein Setup erklären?
Meines Wissens nach hast du Proxmox als Basis.
Was nimmst du für das Naso S?
Open Media Vault.
Das ist so ein Test, gell?
Also das heißt nicht, dass ich das später so machen werde.
Ich will das einfach mal ausprobieren.
Also der Plan ist,
also aktuell
der Plan ist, Proxmox
als Host, da drinnen
eine SSD
für das Betriebssystem
selbst, das ist die, die mit dem
NAS ausgeliefert wird, 64GB, reicht aus
für Proxmox, ja,
Log2RAM, dass es nicht so viele
Rights macht auf die SSD, also eine
Mini-SSD fürs Betriebssystem
Dann zwei
Samsung 990 Pro
SSDs, RAID 1
Und ich weiß
Dass da im Freenas-Forum
Wahrscheinlich alle rumschreien, Max, du kannst doch nicht
Mit Konsumer-SSDs in einem
NAS, doch, das kann ich
Weil so wenig, wie ich da drauf schreibe, im Endeffekt
Machen es die Konsumer-SSDs auch
Also ich hab ein RAID 1
mit
Samsung 990 Pros.
Das Raid 1
macht auch gleichzeitig noch
Encryption
und transparente
Compression. Und die
Compression Ratio ist gar nicht immer
schlecht. Guck dir das mal an hier.
Äh.
Guck mal hier.
Ah ja gut, ich hab jetzt die Sachen gelöscht.
Guck mal, aber allein schon hier
fast nichts drauf, 30 Gig gespart mit Compression.
So.
So sieht das, dann habe ich noch eine Festplatte
zum Testen aktuell drin, eine ganz olle
WD-Creen mit 2TB
zum Testen, da ist aber auch ZFS drauf.
So, dann habe ich
die Festplatte,
einen Ordner von der Festplatte
und einen Ordner von dem RAID 1,
NVMe SSD RAID 1,
in eine Open Media Vault
vm durchgereicht und da drin habe ich den merger fs was wenn ich auf den share schreibe erst einmal
alle neue daten auf die ssd schiebt und dann einmal nachts werden die daten von der ssd
runter gemovt auf die hdd das heißt ich habe so schnelle rights über das über übers netzwerk hat
man das soweit verstanden? Snatch. Und konnte man mir folgen? Chat, falls ihr noch irgendwelche
Fragen habt oder was wissen wollt, haut sie jetzt raus. Ich bin 10 Minuten weg. 5 Minuten
wahrscheinlich eher. Das kann ich gar nicht mehr alles beantworten. Kanisterkoppel, danke
für den Sub, falls ich nicht gesagt habe. Gut, hier wird mitgeschrieben. So mag ich
demnächst prüfung hast du nass drives ich habe aktuell in der kiste drin uhr uhr uhr alte wd
green zwei terabyte zum testen und ja ich habe ein drive bestellt heute bei amazon 499 euro
26 Terabyte.
Problem ist nur, das ist eine externe
HDD.
Die wird
geschuckt nächste Woche.
Und dann hoffe ich,
dass es keine SMR-HDD
ist, die sich ganz gut
dann für mein Nassbild
eignet. Ich muss schucken, genau.
Nee, warum?
Ich schocke mir die an, die HDDs.
Frage wegen der 2TB SSD.
Kann man die nicht... Doch, kann man.
Doch, doch, das geht.
Das könnte man machen. Doch, doch.
Das ist möglich. Ja.
Das ist im Prinzip genauso, wie du es sagst.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
funktioniert das mit dem durchreichen Guthaben
in einem Forum gelesen, dass es gar nicht so geil ist
wenn man keinen eigenen HBA Controller
hat um den ganzen Elfheim
also, falls das das Freenas Forum
ist, beziehungsweise das Trunas Forum
da sind die Leute teilweise richtig
hart drauf, ja, da wurdest du
früher geflamed, also
das würde ich alles mal mit so einer Prise Skepsis
sehen, was die da schreiben
da wurdest du auch
früher geflamed von manchen Leuten für
dass wenn du nicht ein Gigabyte RAM, ECC RAM, ohne ECC RAM, Leute, ZFS ohne ECC RAM,
Freenas Forum, so geht's aber nicht. Anzeige, direkt, kein ECC RAM.
Ja, also so war das Freenas Forum früher drauf.
Und dann muss ECC RAM mindestens ein Gigabyte pro Terabyte, ja, also da wird viel erzählt,
viel erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist. Die haben
aber prinzipiell damit natürlich
Recht. Also wenn
du wirklich Sachen machen möchtest, wie
ZFS zum Beispiel, und
da verschiedenste Zwischenschichten
drin hast,
unterhalb von deinem ZFS-Filesystem,
dann ist das
nicht so geil. Das würde ich nicht machen.
Deswegen mache ich das Ganze ja auch anders.
Ich habe ein ZFS
auf meinem Proxmox.
hier siehst du da
hier ZFS Proxmox
und ich
reiche da nur einen
Ordner der schon
besteht auf diesem ZFS
in mein Open Media Vault durch
per Wirt IO
FS
hier guck
der reicht die Ordner durch
das ist oberhalb von ZFS
Open Media Vault hat von ZFS
überhaupt kein blassen Schimmer
Das ist aus meiner Sicht vollkommen in Ordnung
Das kann man machen
Was würdest du sagen
Leute dafür hab ich jetzt
Ich muss jetzt wirklich aufklären
Also das kann ich
Ich mach dir einen Vorschlag
Wir machen das so
Hat das Ding hier eine Notiz-App?
Cache.ios?
Note?
Oh Gott.
Alter, new file.
Ich schreibe mir das auf.
Und nächsten Stream.
Wenn du da sein solltest.
In einem der nächsten Streams.
Dann sag mal, dass du da bist.
Dann besprechen wir das.
Okay.
Das kriege ich jetzt nämlich nicht in 2 Minuten mehr hin.
bevor du die schubs können wir gucken ob es smr oder cms ja das sollten wir machen
ok leute das letzte was ich euch noch zeigen wollte guckt ich habe jetzt club ihr habt gesehen
plump punkt bin wird nur mit 120 mb die sekunde geredet jetzt habe ich plump punkt bin obwohl es
genau am gleichen Ort liegt, auf meinem Samba-Share,
aber unter der Haube woanders,
auf die SSD gemovt und wenn ich jetzt
Plupp.bin kopiere, werdet ihr feststellen,
das ist
eine ganze Ecke schneller.
Jetzt kommt es nämlich von der SSD.
Da sieht man, MergerFS
funktioniert.
Und das nächste Mal
testen wir das Ganze
in einem LXC-Container
und gucken mal, ob wir vielleicht
noch 100, 200 MB
oder so rausholen können, weil
ich mein, theoretisch, ne,
theoretisch,
haben wir da noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben.
Alles klar.
Chat. Schön, dass ihr
alle dabei wart. Wenn ich irgendwelche Fragen
übersehen hab, schreibt's einfach
nächsten Stream wieder hin. Werde ich alles beantworten.
Wir sehen uns. Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.